hello everyone and welcome back to our
broadcast I apologize for the
interruption with the lag but we needed
to recalibrate it and hopefully
everything will go swimmingly well of
course we are in the chest Bowl masters
we are in what we would call the
business stage of things as the prelims
are over and the quarterfinals have
begun we're in day one and the players
will be playing sets of games for each
day and they need to win two out of
three days there'll be five days in
total as the matches are staggered over
those first four days
Peter pick it up for us before we went
on our unscheduled break yeah there's
been a development in the in an apology
artemiev game which I've been I've been
very surprised by two decisions in a row
there and I wanted to ask for your
guidance yes we left it we left it
somewhere around here after b3 queen 87
Bishop d3 Quincy 5 it's very
understandable young played a3 black
played CC c6 oh boy my body Slav and in
this position yang took the decision to
take on c6 which is already a little bit
surprising to me I don't quite know why
he needed to do it this quickly but I
was I mean shocked I tell you is
probably a little bit of an oven over
reaction but it did surprise me that
item you've chose to take with the pawn
here I would have thought now that the
knight only 7 suddenly is given is being
gifted this quite nice square on c6 I
would have been very interested in that
option much more than I would be in the
idea of taking with the b-pawn in
particular if the follow-up is as they
have played 22 and then black decided
not even to fight against the push of b3
before and played visual musics
seriously stunning developments for me
to probably d5 takes c6 would have been
maybe my third choice and principle when
I look at
pawn on d5 and the pawn on e4 and I look
at that night on e7 I go I'm a hero look
what I'm doing I'm pressing my opponent
and keeping him cramped taking on c6 and
allowing the knight new life one sees on
the c6 square mmm no I'm not a big fan
of that and then the surprising
recapture with the beep on maybe not so
bad after all the the beep on there is a
weakness potential weakness on the B
file for white that he better alleviate
with the move B to before which he's
done by the way overall I think that
black will be satisfied this slightly
backward d6 pawn can very easily be
defended
sometimes even the knight on f6 to e8
actually voluntarily drops back very
very hard to attack the d6 pawn I'm not
exactly sure what neat neppo was
thinking in terms of where is he gonna
get his advantage maybe he's banking on
c4 c5 come I think so yeah I was I was
waiting for you to mention that because
I think that that would be the major
major worry for black here [ __ ] but
right when C 723 played in the meantime
you do constantly have to watch for c4
c5 now because right this often leads to
some very uncomfortable situations for
black I'm wondering if he is actually
intending to do something like c5 be 597
just maybe not 97 but actually night and
I see it drops a rook so that's not very
comfortable but placed one of his
knights on b6 and say this is a
rock-solid position the bishop on f1 is
very passive and it's actually quite
difficult to activate it and I'm not
that worried about this protected
pasaran be fine but it's a it's a very
Hollis a concrete wrote a very committal
decision yeah like okay you're not
coming back from that this is the
structure you've given you've given your
opponent and your Knights are kind of
uniquely uniquely poorly placed to for
instance fight for the d4 square because
this guy would have would have would
have liked to have this
square available to him but that's not
gonna happen so I guess black would
maybe try for something like this 97 f8
let me do this again
97 f-86d 4 but that there is a four move
maneuver and why probably will have
something to say about it uniquely
poorly placed obviously you're not
familiar with my games either uniquely
poorly I liked your approach though I
like 97 immediately I saw 97 as being
one of those fashionable prophylactic
moves that keep your options open you
yes c5 is on tap potentially yes Knight
f8 to e6 to d4 is a maneuver you might
consider especially with the move f7 f6
as a part of that so I like the
flexibility of 97 for all of the reasons
that you were expressing Luke agy okay
Devon I also quite like keeping yourself
as many pieces on the board as possible
and hinting that Queen d2 might be an
awkward move to face although black does
have Knight see it as a reply to that
exact yeah I was wondering about 95 but
I suspect black is not that unhappy
about having to play Knight of faith in
this position so for even night yeah
yeah alright at least we had to look in
on this game as well go back to the
marquee matchup between them for one
number two what's taken what's
transpired Peter well this is the the
structure we were described describing
earlier but hang on a second what just
happened here what just happened is how
is Queen b7 not winning material Queen
a3 perhaps yeah either Queen a3 or maybe
not I was also wondering about Knights
eb6 and if you take on c6 maybe I can do
this and win some material ok right dad
yeah I had to cut myself off it at the
pass here because after 97 at first
glance Queen b7 appears to be a very
dangerous move that you have to worry
about
but both 996 and also yassir's move
Queen a3 they do appear to
cover the the issues efficiently for
instance Quincy seeks Quincy want in
takes eight black does have the move
Queen takes c3 which not only picks up a
full piece but also covers the nikon c8
yeah maybe maybe it's not that dream I
wanted to attract attention to Fabia's
reply to before which I thought was very
cleverly in especially he played Ruby 8a
eight seemingly returning the rukon on a
starting square but considering where
the white rocks are this slows down wise
progress quite a bit makes the b4 b5
move for instance right now pretty much
impossible because of the the pin now
and that resulted in in Magnus going for
a5 and d5 using this x-ray to support
his pawn break but like at least a cut
to his set up unscathed and and then
some pieces were exchanged on the a6
square and we are where we are yeah that
hasn't been played yet maybe seven radio
down the board yeah or not yet no not
just seven is between b7 I hasn't been
played yet I started I pushed a little
bit too far there along already entered
well you know sorry
it may be boring to many but for me this
was a position or at least the type of
position that I always aspire to when I
was white I really really felt good
about my winning chances even though the
material has been reduced I really felt
I had control of the game in the sense
that I could tie my opponent to the
glaring weakness on the c6 were and I
really like this move 92 by Magnus as
well because you you had mentioned and I
thought it was a very nice comment you
were mentioning Peter of bringing the
Knight to d6 that the night on the d6
where it's a lot of squares potentially
Bishop f5 the c-4 square the e4 square
in in a kind of very strange way
night coming to d3 does the same thing
but in a reversed order and I can sort
of thing yeah that for me Magnus is play
is how do you say really clear and
understandable you want to play Knight
f4 so that you can go Knight to d3 and
95 and basically you're just gang up and
you hit that c6 pawn with all your might
and you know if it falls off the board
then it's a strategically winning and if
it doesn't fall off the board black as
you can see right now the rook is on v6
kind of ties these pieces up towards its
defense the knight will go to e7 and
before you know it
white is the one dictating the action
and that no Queen a5 is a kind of an
indication that not all is that well
with blacks position no yeah and I
wanted to also serve and additionally
point out that in after 92 Ruby 8 may
have been already sort of a
mathematically only move because if you
play something like 26 now Queen b7
probably does win the c6 pawn on this
pawn so Ruby 8 more or less forced Ruby
6 pretty much also first you never want
to play 97 and now if the Queen a 5 I
think the point of Queen a5 is black
would very much like to play 96 but now
we can use the fact that the rook on d6
is slightly unprotected right and play
95 which could honestly just result in
the complete collapse of the black over
the black set up because the pawn is
hanging 97 Queen takes B 6 is also a
large threat and Fabiana is reduced to
playing Queen b6 instead no and now
Knight a4 and yeah that night on c8 is
still looking for some kind of green
pastures here it's a it's not looking
all that great I have to say well
exactly and again it's not everybody's
cup of tea but I personally really found
White's position a lot of fun I mean as
young teaming with
the sunny side of the torture and one of
the most difficult I think skills that
that really challenge not just
grandmasters but every type of player is
those positions were players defending
passively I mean the positions not
terrible or anything like that it's just
that you don't have a lot of fun you
don't have a lot of counter play and I
think for a lot of players it's really
easy to collapse when just being
challenged by nagging nagging moves
constantly very hard to play to defend
difficult positions without counter play
these players number one in number two
in the world they're skilled at even
doing that but it's not the way you want
to play I think that fabbi at this exact
moment will probably say he's okay but
maybe I'm not even I think that
particular constellation of pieces
doesn't inspire a great deal of
knowledge he had played 90 87 just now
after 95 right once again I suspect he
is just intending to play something like
Ruby eight and hope that nothing bad
happens to his position tactic naming
drops but I would need to I would need
to stare at this for a bit before I
would be prepared to say that that
assessment is correct like I can play
queen a7 here for instance and if you
just blithely take only five after de my
queen is attacking all kinds of things
and maybe I have to clean before you're
still alive somehow miraculously but it
really does look very very dodgy very
tough so yeah this is this is a bit of a
scary position to be honest so I'm very
interested to see what transpires and in
terms of like that the narrative I was
describing earlier where in the clutch
finals they were seemingly purposefully
playing the sharpest lines possible it
hasn't happened in the
game I think this is these days
considered to be a solid but you know
non-explosive way to to play the opening
for black but I think Magnus will be
very happy with the outcome of I mean
it's move 31 it's hard to call this the
outcome of the opening but in some ways
when you talk about Carlsbad's
the solution kind of does feel like an
outcome of the opening yes yes very much
so one of the things actually Peter that
really is surprising for me is in this
particular position that still exists I
haven't seen a variation where you can
do it yet a background check mate I mean
you would think after 31 moon-like would
have gotten into hh6 you know looked
going and defending g5 white has gotten
an h3 so there is still some tactical
issue potential technical issues are on
of a back rank that could be
disconcerting absolutely I think it's a
very enjoyable position from Agnes it's
not it doesn't mean that he will
necessarily win it you know but it's
very pleasant pleasant to look at and he
goes Knight takes c6 which is very
interesting because it really isn't an
obvious choice but I guess he found some
tactical justification for it perhaps if
you take with the Queen maybe after 95
your position does just collapse
tactically and that means that f e6 and
5ik late fe six more or less
instantaneously which does sort of seem
to indicate that they both came to it
they both came to the same conclusion
that this needed to be done and it's
kind of how would we call it y
transforming one one type of an
advantage into a different type now the
black king is not entirely safe you can
definitely entertain some ideas of
playing g3 h4 and putting the bishop on
h3 where it will look you know
quizzically at the pawn on e6 and black
will have to think about that constantly
every move I it's not an obvious
decision by any means but it's a if
every six is forest which does appear
to be the case then I can definitely
understand why Magnus became interested
by this transforming one advantage in
and to another Peter let me just
interrupt you and take us over to our
social media as Anna will tell us what's
going on thank you so much yes sir and
thanks to everybody tuning in on Twitch
you monitoring those three chests and
the hype is real but also reminder to
you that you do have a question of the
day if we could bring up once again our
slide showing the viewers today's
question which is what makes chess
such a rich pastime and sport and here
are some of the responses we have
received so one being from your own wolf
legacy mix Chester rich game we talked
about tal Fischer Kasparov etc and
electricity of their play but we Neil
fights can talk about Yan pays just in
Jordan I hand the game to my kids and we
work to master the game together and
they to their kids
hashtag study test that's a beautiful
tweet Ian thank you so much another
response to the same question is from
ninety Quranic chess has not only
broaden my mind on the board but in
everyday life too it has changed how I
approach a problem and view the world
it's much much more than just a game
it's a way of life I think I heard that
sentence that chess is life thank you
for your tweet naic and therefore I know
tweet from this segment is from Leon
what don't thank you alone for the tweet
and for all the amazing news articles as
well it's a way to your heart to do
anything other than watch Magnus versus
Fabian right now on chest 24 and it is
indeed a really hard day for everybody
including the players Magnus Carlsen is
not wearing his jacket he is in Denmark
in a beach house and I believe Fabiano
is at home in st. Louis but a very hot
day for heated up action over the board
so back to you yes sir and Peter to
cover what's going on in the position
right now between the policy and
artemyev yeah I just wanted to do do a
quick update on this because that
position
I think solidified very much in White's
advantage
artemyev did play for the plan i
described of c5 b5 and then placing a
very nice assuming the blockading night
on the b6 square but 5 has a complete
control over the D file of the d6 pawn
is under a lot of pressure there is a
very beautiful night only 3 supporting
the pawn on c4 and also kind of glancing
in in those directions and young just
opened direct hostilities with g4 g5 and
it does feel to me like this has a you
know very good chances of succeeding the
point being
after fh d5 we just go back to f3
creating a fair of 95 but also a third
Knight takes e5 because of the the beam
along the G file this looks very
dangerous for black I have so far failed
to refute win take c4 but if you have to
play GF King takes f6
my guess is white is just not that upset
about this even just playing Knight of 3
quietly and continuing with is a
reasonably reasonably quiet moves but
arterian disagrees and goes at 65 that's
so that's quite interesting to me well
definitely heating up there when anna
you mentioned chess is life I think
about Viktor Korchnoi
chess biography book chess is life and
indeed the the games are definitely
heating up by the way I the more I look
at it you had mentioned in the game of
Magnus and fab II Peter an idea of
playing g2 g3
and h3 h4 bringing the bishop to h3 so
you could put a lot of pressure on in a
6 I just took a glance at that position
going on over there and I saw a bishop
on g4 and they said oh that's that's
that's cold that looks
sorry--but to my eyes fab ease in huge
trouble now yeah I think he might just
be lost and interestingly Magnus went
sort of exactly for the position we were
talking about but with a bit of a twist
I was suggesting 95
here no but with that that same idea of
Ruby 1887 if you remember we were
discussing this and Magnus went for
exactly the same line but with the
inclusion of 96-86 I don't know why he
felt it was so important to include it
but I did
after Magnus played it because that
obviously is a stamp of approval
I did find how this is refuted I kind of
cut it off there saying maybe black is
surviving black actually doesn't survive
because I'm in d7 King of seven what I
missed originally was the fact that Roxy
shakes because of the pin on the seventh
rank just picks up everything yeah
because of that Fabia was forced to go
back to g8 and now Bishop e2 and Bishop
g4 and Magnus is just sort of in full
collection mode here oh no question
about it and again black structure is
like one of those leaky bucket kind of
structures where you know there's just
nothing redeeming in Blacks you know the
the pawn is on c4 and you lose the e6
pawn maybe you can make some kind of
claims but it just feels like the the
the the structure is about to be
harvested and we just didn't see the
move Knight g6 and okay you can either
start with rook c6 and rookie six or f4
and just say it's two black keep all the
weaknesses on your side of the table
please leaky structures I believe we do
have a piece sacrificing the game
between your Persian artemyev whoa
that's that's a very exciting
development I was arguing for the move
Knight of three in that position after
35 but Yan says no my position is good
enough to just start directly giving
mate for the King on g7 g f king tonight
takes a five and i think it's very easy
to believe this to be earth at the this
might work because of just you know
there is a whole bunch of pieces on the
queenside which will not be
participating in the defense of his
majesty at all and yeah that will be
there will be a very large very large
issue here for
for Team I don't quite see exactly where
the mate is I'll be honest with you I
haven't figured out how to win for
instance after something like king I
don't know g8 or h8 maybe just not the
xt6 is the plan
if king g6 I suspect Yun is intending to
play Queen h3 but even here so far after
Queen takes e4 I don't see how we win by
force but it looks very very attractive
and also beyond explaining what I will
but I very much like to see in this game
as as a as a friend of yawns I I do know
him a lot better than then I know
vladislav and I I don't know if I'm
extremely biased but I definitely am
have a lot more personal history with
Yun than I do with his younger opponent
I like the Hsien actually spend time on
moves is what I wanted to say I feel
like when he is not you know on on
sixteen and a half minutes by mu 38 this
is when he is generally playing his best
and it seems to me like he's playing a
measured game taking time on decisions
when time needs to be taken on decisions
and if he went for the sacrifice my
first instinct is to trust him on this
because he had he had other options none
none of this was forced RTF is also down
to 44 seconds which i think is quite
unusual for him I think he normally is a
very quick player qing-ge a queen g3 and
g4 play the board Queen takes a bit
there you know I've always kind of
thought as as nepo as some kind of you
know high-speed performance car like
almost Ferrari like he makes his
decisions very very quickly almost like
again with blazing speed and sometimes
you almost want to say to young young
slow down just tap the brakes go around
the curve a little bit slowly you know
don't crash out of position but when
he's in here
his gear in his top gear he's a threat
to anybody in the world yeah
so far the only thing I found that I
liked for white are sort of unreservedly
might end up being a draw in there and
you could just take on the six here and
take again this creates a lot of threats
to the black king and I think black
probably will be obliged to go for this
endgame check on a1 check on a
four-in-hand rook takes b6 but black
does have rook c1 in this position and
my suspicion is this might actually hold
Wow
440 F so I'm very interested in looking
for something that is more I would I
would like if this were my position with
white right now
in particular when I have like four
minutes against 58 seconds and we really
are in no hurry whatsoever here if we're
playing does it make a difference if I
take twice with the rook on d6 am i I
was wondering about that but I think we
because g7 is not hanging I think black
still has the same defensive resource
right so that it's a it's a it's a very
relevant question because not allowing
black 2 to take twice would be it would
be a very attractive for a position but
I don't think it quite works out another
way to go would be something like Ruby
g3 and just as I was mentioning it this
is what he played but I a 1 on the board
in an instant Peter and that's exactly
what I was worried about yeah until I
saw okay one I thought would be three
might just be the absolute winning move
here right okay one worried me quite a
bit because it seems to me like we will
not have to allow a rook trade and
what's even more unfortunate we're
probably going to have to trade the
active rope not the passive one we will
end up with a rook on the first rank
which is not really doing very much so
I'm curious to see if Yun has a what I
never Reggie made reply to this well no
I I think I take
- many aye I feel good about taking
liberties with other people's pieces
look a three here or something yeah rep
g3c g3 route g3 is even and I go King h2
and I don't know are we actually
threatening mate and particularly fight
beam euro kanji 3 so the right never
gives any choice
am I actually can i construct a mate and
I think the King prob'ly ends up being
reasonably safer on the 6th square here
sadly for God the Romantics among us
that will be very annoying
yeah I'm sorry I again I taking
liberties with Yuans pieces and time is
not yet a factor well it kind of is hmm
yeah I think sadly rookie Vaughn may
have been missed
if Yun doesn't blitz out the reply after
room d3 okay Juan and I should probably
be looking at a very very small window I
have on my screen which shows the
players faces and I young is a very very
emotive emotive player it's it's a lot
of fun to watch him play chess because
he doesn't really hide his his feelings
almost at all but I did miss the moment
Andrew b3 okay one had been played and I
often you can tell by the way he reacts
to the the new situation on the board or
in the mover nod he's down to a minute
now and then I think is a very large
indication that he mr. great one and
always he oh he did by rock a1 by the
way but I was looking also at a knight
h6 check and hoping that I would get
some checks against Blacks team I said
we always have that option I think it so
it's not really very likely that that
option will ever be taken away from us
and in the meantime Magnus did win Game
one
firstly I will just show the final
position for now roof total dominance in
the center the entire blitek structure
disappeared so no real surprise that
black resigned here and get back to our
sharp Spanish well with when the rooks
were on the board I thought that night
h6 kind of meant and it's played rukka
three here
that's real very you I don't I don't
know what that is
I think it's probably an attempt to give
a perpetual right I think if you take
this rope I think after Knight h6 check
we probably have a perpetual like kingi
828 King is 725 and the king action
never reaches the DA square right and
and we always have the perpetual check
here but we clearly never have any any
kind of a mating attack here we don't
have enough attackers people add I think
if say no me well he probably didn't
have anything anything smarter and they
are playing on very very low time so for
for our team if to play Queen debunking
h2 and say I have an extra piece yes I
don't quite see how my king gets safe
but I will play on because I have an
extra piece it's a very difficult
decision I don't think very many people
do that so I think Queen takes a three I
think is a very understandable choice
here and I think and I think it ends up
being a draw now the this is game one in
the quarterfinals so with the black
pieces with little time you you really
have to have nerves of steel I want to
say yeah if we say no to that draw fur
would be would be a very difficult
proposition but very nicely very nicely
found found motif by by yon on the other
hand I want to check like if if we don't
play root K 3 is this still a drawer or
no probably not because now we can go
King e6 and there is never any queen of
five checks you know I mean GA check the
king can go to f6 and then to g6 and you
might not have that perpetual anymore I
think this is I think this is why he he
gave up the rook first because he needed
to make sure that the King can not
really cross over to some kind of g6
squares and yeah the game probably has
been drawn because in in the current
position we have on our screens black
has one legal move and he is not making
it uh-huh so I assume I assume there's
there's been some kind of
conclusion because nothing else really
makes any sense really hoping it's not
whoa
what Oh No
we must have had a disconnect
oh no be there would be very very
unfortunate if if this is not not some
kind of a glitch because it's it's
clearly a position in which Y does have
the perpetual but but no there's only
one move for black so there's no and
also and also yeah yeah
Kimmy sixty-seven would have been played
instead of resigning in this position if
if you had a technical capability of
making a move we will we will seek
guidance before from our why don't we
just take a quick break and get in some
commercial sponsor words so that we
ourselves can figure out what happened
in this very eventful first round we'll
see on the other side of this break
everyone
[Music]
you
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Cara Juana
Alexander Chris Chuck and bent Allah
Hari Krishna Co premium at chess 24 to
challenge them and gain full access to
the world's most entertaining chess
platform
now anyone can learn and improve their
chest skills with the world champion
Magnus Carlsen
the Magnus trainer app is packed with
fun minigames an interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the Magnus trainer available in the App
Store and Google Play
[Music]
[Music]
you
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery magnus
carlsen introduces chasuble
the definitive solution for studying
chess move trainer uses the science of
spaced repetition to identify your
strengths and eliminate your weaknesses
there's no need to set up a board to
remember which page you're on or keep
track of all the moves you miss move
trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the endgame with confidence
it's a seamless effective and fun way to
study chess choose from one of the
largest online chess libraries in the
world
with hundreds of titles ranging from
classic books due to our exclusive
chasuble courses including over 100 free
courses get expert insights from
international Master John Bartholomew
Graham Master Sam Franklin's
International Master crystal select
Grand Master Simon Williams world's
champion Magnus Carlsen and hundreds of
other instructors get started now and
join our growing community of over
100,000 chess enthusiasts at jezebel.com
chasuble take control of your journey
towards chess mastery everyone and
welcome back to our live coverage of the
quarterfinals of the chasuble masters
what an eventful first game we just had
as vladislav did disconnect and lost the
game by forfeit and when he came back he
was looking so terrible but that first
round was amazing as it featured a
pretty nice a learning moment that anna
is going to take us through step by step
of what Napo missed honor indeed it was
a very inspiring PE sacrifice by young
yep Amish midnight f5 earlier on he
played a group t3 in this position in
his game after which rook a1 was a
brilliant defense by Artemyev and if it
wasn't for the disconnection the game
would have ended in a draw what was the
winning move instead of Ruby d3 is
extremely instructive and also very
difficult Queen g7 check
if King to e6 now Queen age six check
and the knight is untouchable
if King takes f5 the winning move is can
you guys spot it now gonna be easy
pawn to f3 push them baby yes sir
the Queen has to go and then g4 will be
a pawn checkmate or black has to give up
the Queen for the pawn and there's no
way of getting out of this for instance
if after the Queen check on h6 black had
gone back to f7 for instance if we go
back to that moment white will force
this position by playing Queen takes h7
now if King let's say King f6 then Queen
h6 there's just no way of getting out of
this position because King f7 back then
we have Queen g7 check and King yet
Queen g8 is made and if King to e6 Queen
g6 is made so that was absolutely no way
out of the meeting that would have been
a beautiful finish instead unfortunately
for our team you have it was the
disconnection that decided the game in
the end
wow what a learning moment Peter two
games two victories what a way to start
the quarterfinals absolutely very
exciting first round two very different
games in in character
Magnus winning you want to say a kind of
a typical Magnus game getting a very
pleasant edge from the opening and then
never really letting it go and
calculating cleanly and and far when
when the position required it because I
think if we go back to that game in this
position we were talking about how
pleasant it is but it did not seem
obvious at least to me that white
already maybe is is close to winning but
Magnus spent some time here and went for
this four sequence of taking and then
playing 95 and queen a7 and I have a
feeling he has already forced seen that
after takes takes Queen d8 might be the
only move and then the very strong
maneuver Bishop e2 followed by Bishop g4
just completely collapses the
the black setup and bones start falling
and indeed Fabi soon ended up with no
bones left in the center if you look at
the final position the dead structure is
just clean gone there's nothing left
mm-hmm and in an impressive positional
squeeze to be sure but gain - has
started and for those of you who are
joining us a little late first of all a
hearty way welcome tell all your friends
where you're hanging out we are in the
quarterfinals day one the players are
going to be contesting for rapid games
with obviously two and a half points
being the key magic number the first
player to score two and a half or better
you could score three wins the day's
action is over in case of a 2-2 tie the
players will then go into blitz mode and
if those games are still tied we'll see
an Armageddon to decide who is the
victor of day one there'll be three days
of play so you have to win two out of
three days these sets of match Peter
take us away Fabi with the white pieces
needing to bounce back yeah and the
choice of the opening for the
bounce-back would have maybe raised some
eyebrows let's say 20 years ago but
these days I think it's well understood
that the Joko piano is really not all
that Joko at all and it's a very sort of
universally accepted way to play for a
win when you have to play for a win a
lot can be said by on the topic of move
orders in in the joke of jana on the
question of how black is supposed to
react to a2 a4 and a2 a4 in general
being very much a choice that came to
prominence reasonably recently comparing
comparing to the old plans so do you
play a 6 here do you play a 5 and these
types of questions are all extremely
intricate and I feel like there's a lot
of people in the world who would be able
to cover it a lot better than I would so
I will just say
those topics exist and try to quietly
move move oh well done that by the way
I've seen even black plate I think it
was Alexander Grisha yes a Chanel Iman
it's a very weird line where there's
there's actually a lot of whatever black
ends up doing does make sense in most
cases but it's very difficult to explain
to the uninitiated and I count myself
honestly among the uninitiated on many
of these topics me too I raised my hand
and say look feeder if you ever want to
try to explain this one to me you know
I'll give you an entire month veto
because it is very complicated and I do
remember a very nice interview with
five-time world champion this one Athan
a nun and he said it was something like
about oh I'm gonna say ten years ago he
said well it was really crazy we put the
Joko piano in our engines and we discuss
it we discovered much to our
astonishment that the positions were
incredibly rich and we all started
playing the Joko piano and here we just
saw by the way after the move Bishop e6
the move Bishop b5 as fabbi was
reluctant to trade on e6 Peter and why
was he reluctant to not double his
opponents pawns it's an interesting
choice I think playing against those
double pawns is very much a discussion
that is a front and center when people
are playing the piano in particular like
it used to be absolutely commonplace to
start with Ruki a to prepare Bishop e6
to not allow the doubling but these days
people are reasonably happy to play this
position they aim to go for some kind of
knight Age 594 counter play and actually
having the pawn on e5 ends up being
quite advantageous for for black because
it means that white cannot gain
in additional space on that flank with
some kind of some kind of before before
plans but it should be five also exists
in particular with the pawns on a four
and a five you have to ask yourself how
are you replying tonight a seven which
is what Magnus plays instantly and the
answer uh and the answer normally is d3
d4 and here I'm drawn to the idea that
because the rook is on e 1 Peter I
really really want to take the bishop on
b5 with a stupid night on a 7 but I
don't want to trade the dark squared
bishop for it so I want to take on d4
and after c3 takes d4 I want to play
Bishop b4 hahaha tempo against the rook
now if you block me with Knight c3 then
yay I'll take the bishop on b5 and
whether it's good or bad I Pat myself on
the back as as if I accomplish something
wonderful is it yeah interesting Magnus
does take on d4 but after she takes
before he does not play Bishop before
but instead takes on b5 here which is a
little a little bit of a twist I think
you're correct I think might be 5d takes
e5 Knight a7 this position very much
exists in theory with the inclusion I
think of moves Knight bTW - and or maybe
with the knight on g2 and the pollen h2
if you instead of h3 if you play if you
play Knight bTW to hear that position
has been discussed I think there are
some Grizzard games starting from here
there is a famous game between I think
Magnus Carlsen won this position against
West I saw once GD 666 and b3 is how
they how they proceed proceed about
things here but with the pollen history
I haven't seen this before but what
Magnus is doing is he is saying I want
to take more pawns off the board in the
center before I take on b5 and Fabi says
I'm not going to recapture but what
you raised is very interesting because
seemingly there is no reason to even
allow white to take dc5 exactly and if
black hasn't played Bishop before and
also if 5b is specifically aiming for
this position
I suspect they both feel that after
Bishop before and maybe Bishop g2 or
maybe Knight c3 I'm not even sure which
i think is probably Bishop d2 95 a B
they feel that this is good for a for
white or I think otherwise far we
wouldn't have been going for this
position and Magnus Magnus on the other
hand would have gone for this position
I'm just looking at a P term and
thinking to myself you blacks got pretty
darn good development his pieces are out
and on and b5 is weak to my eyes Bishop
yes um yes until I Bishop c4 yeah I'm
very curious why this hasn't been played
to be honest okay and also and also like
if they think this is good for white
somehow yeah why after Knight things
before which is what man has played in
the game why didn't why play hate things
be fine here exactly yeah is this is so
great
is he really more worried about Bishop
b6 here then he is about Bishop before
that's very confusing yeah there's a
logical itch there somewhere but what
has happened is Magnus quickly said to
his opponent look you can have the two
bishops you can even have the better
pawn structure if you like let me get
into an ending that I can draw well
we'll wait wait wait not so fast can yes
monkeys but Agnes draw this and I mean
this is not a pleasant ending and again
- you know the old fashioned way the old
fogey way of thinking to bishops
weakness well the two bishops are may
not happen are gone off the board
honestly oh sorry
what am I still have to I will have to
direct you on this deeds if my bishop on
b5 thank you about that I I'm gonna keep
my mouth shut Peter but yeah the pawn on
d6 is somewhat weak and I think black
but very much like to play
65 at the earliest possible opportunity
because otherwise it might it might be
under a lot of pressure but generally
speaking I think this position lends
itself to mass simplifications in in
many many cases I think black probably
isn't all that unhappy about this I
think what is likely to happen is
something along the lines of let's say
before which is I mean looks like it the
most natural move in the world let's say
I include rook fg8 I'm not sure I need
to but let's play rook fg8 here you go
Roque jiwon and I play e5 d5 and 94 mm
hm and I think some kind of a position
like this very often ends up ends up
being fine for black because yes you can
currently take on e4 and win that pawn
mm but black generates so much counter
play here let's say after I'll give
uncheck followed by Bishop d5 that I
think is not really running any serious
risks at all and if you instead decide
not to take on e4 and play something
like 95 there is a target for counter
play 1a for like I could consider put
maybe even playing Knight c5 here and
starting to attack it straight away
feels to me like black isn't doing all
that poorly I will completely agree with
you and for those people who are
following that nice line you were
showing that Knight takes e4 variation
that you just pointed out hmm
if pawn takes rook takes rook takes okay
yeah rook takes e4 rook Shaq and if you
were thinking well I could go rook e1
well there's more coming off in the a
for pawn at the end of the day gets
eaten as well easy easy draw there for
Magnus okay
well we'll see if AB you can't make some
headway out of this at the moment
looking at looking at him on camera
he doesn't look particularly happy about
his circumstance
how is vladislav doing Ladislav playing
against nepo those of you joining us
late actually he was drawing the final
position he simply disconnected
and his time ran out so that is why
neppo is currently leading this match by
one zip what's happening if they have
blitzed out this this entire sequence so
both of them playing incredibly quickly
I'm somewhat interested by by the
opening here of the Lodi Slough has been
playing these types of openings quite a
bit but interestingly a young himself
has played this line with the white
pieces so he is quite intimately
familiar with the intricacies of this
particular variation this position can
appear from a number of openings of
course this girl can can come as it has
in this game from the c-45 English it
also is one of the central positions of
the the plan of attack in the kurakin so
plenty of different move orders and the
line that Vladislav played takes takes
and Bishop c4 um I'm curious about this
because I think they mainly play Queen
b3 these days first and foremost I think
they play more Queen b3 more than they
play Bishop c4 but also after Bishop c4
Knight takes c3 I'm pretty sure the main
move in this position is Queen b3 right
something that Yan would know really
really well having played this pollution
I think with white quite a bit and also
he is I think currently main main coach
Graham must have bought him a fortune
has contributed a great deal to the
theory of this variation played a number
of very interesting games I think maybe
with both colors even but our team if
instead just plays B takes c3 kind of I
want to call it naive chess I understand
it sir it's a bit stupid it's not naive
chess it's just he believes this is the
way to go here but you know there is a
knight to take so why should I make any
intermediate moves I can just take the
knight but and does allow black to
immediately play Bishop g7 and castle
without emitting any kind of yeah and
because I've always played the caro-kann
in this particular line of the pan off
bargaining was always considered soft
that is to say this exact position with
the pawn on c3 and
King you are the safely askance tan you
know there did that there's ideas of
Queen c7 and getting counter play
against the c3 I never thought that this
was a danger that's why you were
mentioning Queen b3 and Bishop c4 as
white word was oftentimes aspiring for
more than what he gets in the game let's
see how the game continued yeah muscles
are telling it played very logically
rook e1 followed by Bishop g5 I think is
the most natural way to develop your
thesis but this this led to a very
forcing continuation from the moment he
who played Queen c7 and after h3 snapped
off one of three and took on d4 she
takes d4 Queen takes e4 Bishop e7 and
rook fv8 black is clearly aiming to just
completely equalize here by liquidating
everything in the center but so far he
is not having such an easy time of it
arching a true kg1 and here if you just
look at this position without discussing
and create variations for a second I
think it should be rather obvious that
if you somehow manage you get get that
pawn all the way to d6 well somebody
like me will start having a you know
very very unpleasant flashbacks because
the amount of games I lost due to
Vladimir Kramnik
who's done this to me in all kinds of
green fields is is very painful to
recall and you really need to fight it
against the g56 idea which is why I'm
very sure
yon didn't really consider for instance
Queen takes a to for more than three
seconds you just cannot allow g56 it's
too dangerous and he has played a move
which I thought was very clever Queen c7
attacking the bishop on e7 and hoping to
maybe trade off some some rooks and
establish a blockade in particular
driving this bishop away from me e7
Square makes the whole d5 d6 plan while
still dangerous are a lot less dangerous
I would feel but cleanly three is a very
smart reply by vladislav keeping the
bishop firmly on only seven and now
d5 is
looming very large I still feel how do
we feel about this heavy piece end game
Yas after Bishop f8 well whenever I'm in
these heavy piece major piece endings we
say I'm always looking at who has the
most potent pond and I'm looking and I'm
saying okay it's white for choice
how big an edge that's completely
something we can argue of course but
well white White's for choice black
black will try to blockade and and say I
can hold but um yeah I'm also I'm
agreeing leader to such an extent that
I'm actually seriously wondering if I'm
supposed to trade more major pieces here
and actually give up on a7 which is
which is an unhappy choice but I would
like to at least like entertain this
thought because if instead black takes
on a phage straight away we do allow
both the immediate d5 and also maybe
rookie 7 followed by d5 d6 is also
something that needs to be very
seriously considered I'm not sure this
is fun for black at all no no I I really
don't think this is fun and you know
young also agrees with us because he's
been he's been thinking for I think
close to 5 minutes now and hasn't played
this buffet 2 yet or anything else for
that matter
not-not-not a nice situation where did
it go wrong because really it feels to
me that yan played all the sensible
correct moves from 4 in 94 but he has
landed himself in a little troubled
water
yeah I'm not I've also been kind of
asking myself that because the entire
sequence seemed very logical but then it
ended up it ended up here and and he's
nothing else played by the way b5 his
play to move I did not expect saying yes
please play d5 if you want but why would
we we might be good some of those
painful memories you mentioned because
d5 d6 is definitely on white's agenda
yeah maybe he just wants to play a v d6
Queen d7 and claim that he has some
counter play on the Queen side but
that's extremely risky
if you imagine yeah G 555 played let's
say d6 Queen d7 if but save the rook
curve from c1 lands on c7 at some point
in the game just pretty much ends right
currently he will have some kind of
before Bishop c3 account to play against
it apart from the obvious rook e1 rook
c8 which is also not immediately refuted
but yeah this is I don't think this is a
happy choice i dont think blacc ever
does this you know with with a with a
with a fist pump but got in a5 yeah baby
yeah like I I think I think this is this
is not one of those one of those very
happy positions you're absolutely dream
of but maybe it's not that bad maybe the
[ __ ] 27 just will touch on that it's a
very strong piece it blocks in the
trades only file it supports the passive
very well but it's also in the way of
white zone play to some degree because
it makes it impossible to even plan for
some kind of a rookie 7 ideas so I still
like this for white but having stared at
this for a minute now may be honest
correct maybe there is not
thing you need to be finding about just
yet
and if I try to maneuver my queen to
like the G for square Peter or something
like Queen f3 dg4 that's uh yeah that's
scary but maybe we can go or okay seven
and claim that we still have things
somewhat under control
I don't know I'm worried I would be
worried - I'm not too sure exactly the
sequence something like rook defy for
example I'm just saying I don't know
about you but whoops that's a B for pawn
oh yeah give me that pretty tat yeah
it's very awkward yeah maybe we have to
play whisper fate at some point and
start combining combining our normal
play with some ideas of Bishop dating c7
but I mean this could very easily just
completely blow up backfire for black
like you occasionally you get made to
them positions like this also
if white manages to start something on
the Kings side it's just Gary your group
held their experiences haha oh Jesus get
made it was a bad luck Peter bad luck
okay
so potential there for vladislav to try
to tie up the match
how's it going in our marquee matchup
with the world champion and the world's
number two well well the things we were
describing sort of came came to pass and
Magnus didn't even include Ruby g8 from
Devon he played for that pick she won't
sacrifice straightaway Chladni picked it
up and he just played rock fg8 with the
intention of Ruby three five we decided
not to stop with probably because rookie
three in 94 also looks very awkward so
rusev on Ruby three Ruby three rook 88
and I think here a very major part of
why this is completely fine for black
and maybe even a little bit more than
fine is the difference in activity of
those two nines there's a knight on c6
completely restricts the knight on f3
and black is more or less entirely free
to go after the White King side which is
what happened take stakes
three mangas played rugby three and then
room before and they're currently
playing this ten game which I assume
should people drawn with good play from
from the white side but it's once again
not a lot of fun for for the white
player here because before Bishop
default played if you imagine black
player okay to a four and A three mom's
actually played b3 which surprises me a
little bit I think maybe he thinks he
could be winning I mean a winning is a
bit strong but normally you don't want
to give this bishop a very very nice
safe square on interest on c3 but I
think after Bishop c3 or c4 there's all
kinds of tactics which Magnus prob'ly
feels are very interesting in particular
after like the very normal looking King
a3 a4 King III a3 probably wins on the
sport because you cannot take the b-pawn
actually Queens because the bishop
controls both the 8c 8 and B 3 from from
a6
a nice pattern that is very worth
remembering everybody when you see that
anchored bishop on the c3 square with
the pawn on B to kick out the legs from
under it with the move a3 and that
sacrifice that Peter just showed
followed by b2 and its promotion time a
very nice pattern there Peter I think
we've all in our grandmaster lee
experiences have won games precisely by
that tactic you probably more than me
since this almost looks like an
Greenfeld ending that you might have so
a degree yeah normally if one Bishop
survives it's not the LightSquared 1 but
Finity from this position and I think
quite quite interestingly Fabi hasn't
played Bishop c3 yet I think he also
realizes now that he has now but I'm
very interested
to see how he is going to deal with this
also Magnus maybe could even go rugae -
but I like rook c4 better if you play
Roque one you're still faced with the
same problem after a four if they're now
threatening to take and then play b2 and
then to play a three and maybe both of
them will Quinn hang on ah I think I
figured it out we do have the move
Bishop d2 here okay
and by the way very importantly I would
say because otherwise as you've been
seeing black is really turning the
screws there on White's position
absolutely and also it's worth noting
that you have to do it now because once
again if we burn a tempo here of the
Bishop d2 black will win with a three
nice parry because yes you do trade the
ropes but unfortunately for you either
be a b2 or something like Bishop c3a -
both are completely lost and Magnus does
end up playing okay - instead mm-hmm so
the plan now is just to push 8 a 4 a 3
and this is fatty the time he needs to
activate his repeater sort of yes but
also unfortunately for white if you do
if you do this which is very very
logical you still cannot cannot stop a 3
because Ruki 8 runs into whoops the long
diagonal check gotcha
but I think a bigger issue for black
here is that after a b1a4 we could
probably just play something like King
g3a3 room g2 and claim that this setup
is probably very very difficult to shake
we're not obviously we cannot take ba
like after King h7 ba losses on the spot
because the beep on Queens but we can't
play something like a 4 and just wait
more or less indefinitely for black to
eventually capture on b2 then we take
with the bishop and reclaim this kind of
a blockade is like needs more pieces
basically to attack if they're this were
if this were a for rogue position maybe
black would have had some chances but
with only with only this material
on the board this doesn't look like a
very difficult draw for white yeah that
looks rock-solid
to be sure well a difficult start to
this day one for Fabiano as he's
definitely been put on the back foot in
this game if he does manage to draw it
he'll be trailing in the match 1 and 1/2
half and he'll thank his lucky stars not
to be trailing 2-0 how is
Ladislav doing is he getting any closer
to tightening and making the match even
Peter well he's I'm sure he is still
better but it feels to me that this has
been like the Billy I suspect Black is
breathing a little bit easier here the
[ __ ] 27 has been traded off without
allowing rookie 7 without allowing any
kind of a confer concessions either in
center on the Kings side and it's gone
yeah I was about to say well let's find
out what our audience thinks as will
switch over to honor to share with us
Anna obviously
but Tamiya lost in the previous games so
before I head over to the responses we
have received I do want to address that
he did not lose because of the
disconnection disconnection doesn't mean
a lot but the players need to reconnect
within the time they have and if you
lose on time that is a loss in chess
obviously now I've seen couple of
comments in the live chat how this is
unfair the regulations are the
regulations and it is the same for each
and every player artemyev didn't
complain because he knows that this
applies to him just as it applies to
every single other participants I think
we all know that in online competitions
it is something that can happen but it
is the players it is the players who
need to make sure that they have stable
internet connection and as much as you
may think it's fair or unfair these are
how Internet competitions are and I
don't see the comment about how good it
is in terms of its a $1,000,000 magnus
carlsen chest or that is an online
competition now for so many of these
professional players who cannot compete
at over the board event so can we also
fully reflect on how in the midst of a
pandemic we have an online chess tour
with a lot of priced phone at stake that
gives a living to all of these chess
players so please share it also reflect
on the bright side of the online era and
internet internet connection has always
been part of the game but it's not the
disconnection it is the player who needs
to reconnect and finish the game in time
now on to the question of the day which
is if we could bring up our slide again
what makes chess can we please bring on
this slide because I can't remember it
fully what makes chairs such a rich
pastime and sport and some of the
responses include Marten closest saying
the boundless creativity within a very
small playing boundary just 64 squares
but so many ideas and another response I
really like it on Twitter is from also
the anisa saying of course chest has a
rich called
but more than that chess is a universal
language that once you learn it well
enough you understand that is an
expression of art science joy drama and
even humor so you would better
hashtag study chess thank you for your
tweets and the big shot that's all of
you tuning in or youtube tweet and chest
24 earlier on we were the number six
stream on Twitch solely number six in
any category overall on twitch that's
usually thanks to you guys for tuning in
for today's Carson versus Karina and
Artemia versus Naomi she quarterfinals
now back to the action
well thank you honor for that indeed it
is a good reminder to say how grateful
we are to both chasuble and chess 24 for
their partnership and are able to bring
us this top-quality top-notch action and
yes we are going to have technology
challenges and yes there will be Mouse
lips and even disconnections we do our
best to minimize it but hey sometimes
sport is sport and mistakes happen and
that makes it interesting
Peter I'm looking at the vladislav last
move which I like it a lot yeah I think
right yeah it's a very it's a very
interesting move because it combines a
number of ideas first and foremost like
perhaps the the easiest to understand
here is the simple idea of picking up
the phone on b5 and playing an end game
with an extra form which is a problem
but also if black takes only five there
is now a threat of mate in one and after
King g8 I think the point is you can
play rook e1 here ah and create a very
very strong threat of Queen f6 followed
by rook f7 such a strong thread that
even rook g8 doesn't stop it because of
a rather familiar tactic of Queen f6
greentext e6 and now rook e8 check
forcing of the rope to get distracted
and we pick up the Queen on d6 you are
and generally if what
I think the Rudy one is going to be a
reply here as well with the same idea
the same idea and yeah I think Yanis
Young has been tanking here for quite a
bit and I think it's sort of very easy
to see why because well it looked like
maybe the worst was over for him at
least that was my initial impression
somewhere around here but rookie 5 has
shaken that belief quite a bit so very
it's a very strong move I think
very nice very sharp everyday rookie 5
it looks visually very impressive has
fabbi
created a fortress for himself Peter
Magnus found a very very interesting
approach there first of all well I think
it's very important that Phi be in this
position there was already here I think
an option to play a four right which he
chose not to avail himself of he played
King King of three instead and also King
g3 is looking f3 once he looked a little
bit more natural to me and Magnus more
or less instantly I used that to play g7
g5 and to force the forest white to
break apart his own structure with King
III and f4 and then bang was pushed
stage 5 but the the the really turning
point of the game for me uh was I think
that idea in this position my original
thought here was this is just a draw
because if you take on h4 this is a very
easy to draw because you never make any
progress right one extra point is pretty
pretty much always not enough though to
convert into a full point and how do you
ever shift white from the setup but
Martinez found a way he played King g4
h5 King g3 rook h1 King g2 actually
running the rook away from the H file
there is just not enough squares on the
H file for the rook to stay there and
after every murder it left after it left
the h5 Bowen got picked up well now and
now we have we have a position like this
which I still suspect is probably closer
to a draw than it is to a black victory
but it's awkward
no question about it and Magnus very
very happy we know he loves to grind his
opponent down just the smallest
advantages that you give to him he tends
to convert them this you know I mean I
was I was about to say if blacks King
were on a reasonable square f5 or I
think I think he's gone but I think it
might not even be a draw e-even that
might be a drug thing no no I think it
might not be a draw at all it's always
play against the computer yeah but just
the fact that the king is on h3 makes
blacks task still awkward but if Magnus
were to win this game it would give him
a 2-0 lead to start yeah it would feel
like the first set is just gone for five
yes Magnus Magnusson would have the
white pieces in Game three and only
needed a draw to to put that set to bed
and you would think he is a huge
favorite to to do that exactly three
played by Fabi still trying to preserve
the the cut on only the G foul and in
our second game rookie one has been
played and I think I figured out what he
on is planning here I think it might
really be the only move that doesn't
lose I think you're really supposed to
play Queen e6 here okay it's a difficult
decision to to accept because it like it
doesn't look very attractive to start
sacrificing pawns here but I think that
endgame of the takes takes and perhaps
rook she won Ruby Wan should be okay
well and by like for a given for a given
value of okay but sort of sort of okay
but it's sort of like the point that
you're making is Queen e6 whether you
like it or not it might be yeah I
thought III briefly wondered if he can
play the rooks e6 but the answer the
answer is quite simply no an emphatic
because yeah because Queenie eight
Queens Queens the gee-pole on the spot
so right I think he might have to I just
don't see any other options I mean you
can play Queen D
eight here but I have a feeling if you
do this and you allow FINA for work she
for maybe you still have this option but
it looks horrible 25 may be followed by
rookie 7 and just looking perhaps
between six on the board Yan Yan as he
has indeed sacrificed upon to get
himself what he hopes will be a drawn
rook important game an excellent
practical decision I have to say Peter
yeah I think I think he was obliged to
do that and he wasn't happy about it
hence the reasonably long force but but
yeah III don't think he really had any
other serviceable options and now our
team if needs to needs to figure out how
to get the most out of this position
okay so you know I'm thinking that if I
go for this line that you had had had
had given that that's more drawn to me
my eyes and anything I'm more attracted
to an idea like rookie 5 giving up my D
pawn for both the beef 5 and that's what
he played yeah that's yeah and I'm
thinking if I can get three versus three
on the kingside and an a passer on a two
but because the button is on e6 and not
f7 better practical chances than usual
Peter yeah I think so I don't quite know
if that turns the reasonably comfortably
drawn four against three into a lost one
but it definitely makes the task more
more difficult right and so what we're
talking about for everybody is imagine a
move like rook c6 or rook c1 check if
you like
you Peter sure and rook d1 and we're
talking about this specific ending it's
four versus three but this past eight
two point is usually not that worrisome
when the e6 pawn is on the f7 square the
fact that the e6 pawn is kind of
isolated or separated from the rest of
the group
the pawn structure this is where Peter
and I are kind of hedging our bets and
saying also something I wanted to get
clearance from you yes would I be right
in saying that in the classical four
against three if the point is let's say
enough seven the best porn for white to
have is the beep or not the a pawn
correct okay III thought so but I just
don't trust myself a new can game yeah
no the a pawn is actually like one of
the worst well it is the worst barnett
because it doesn't give you a king
enough shelter right that would be
cisely that's exactly the whole point
and we do this is a fascinating indeed I
was just going to say it's a fascinating
see I think all discussion in and games
well we we have very close to the end in
the Carolina Carlson game if we could go
back to it sure yeah ooh okay we had a
lot of thing a lot of things have
changed I mean somehow that was one past
pardon others three now there's three
including one for white but it feels
like the the very very weak King on be
one might actually prove White's undoing
Magnus goes rogue c2 now Bishop d3 is
pretty much a winning threat you have to
stop Bishop d3 at all costs uh-huh he
plays rook c8 a move I actually
blundered this this might be okay now
question mark
King g4 unfortunately for Fabi though he
cannot play six here because he will
lose after Bishop takes c6 replaced e2
and I fi once again I can't draw arrows
worth for them here arrow technique is
not approved but the rest day was still
very very much appreciated nice Peter
Bobby has played rock c6 he's also
playing not not entirely an increment
but on very very low time and the among
us will go AHA this is clever
after King a5 now he can play six
because the bishop is cut off from there
v square and how we can take on c2 and
there is no Bishop a5 in the end so
right maybe maybe Fabi is still holding
after this very very smart very very
smart resource
and Magnus plays Bishop d3 oh I was
sorry I was about to say after wait a
minute I'm gonna still winning yeah I
thought Bishop d3 in that position Peter
are there as well you know that's that's
even stronger yeah you're right
but but I think Magnus feels that this
is just winning so yeah I think that's
right as well sake stakes and now he
goes king of five and the bishop will
actually get torn apart because of the
bishop the [ __ ] e4 you cannot keep
the pawn on e5 alive and also stop the F
pawn queening and I assume some kind of
a position like this is not going to
hold right yeah it's just a very easy
win for black right go go around that
corner player 3 and the y position
collapses absolutely absolutely this is
completely winning when you win when
it's two versus zip I need to be if they
need to be closer to each other for more
white to have drawing chances if they
were on C and E files that position
probably is a draw because the King can
can cover both of them but not when
they're on C and F that's that's a
little bit too much Bobby goes bishop ba
but that doesn't change anything we
still play a three here and exactly the
leaf iPhone falls
yeah the assumption is this is just very
easily winning from left right I just
don't see how it wouldn't be Wow well
art just start along that route yeah
what of what a disastrous start to fabbi
we at the top of the show on a second
king of five should be three kings
before Qing yuan is this yeah King g3 is
winning yeah that's still winning but
let's say if we play King h3 king of two
this probably is still winning but it
will take some work right it you you
have to go back and forth and eventually
I guess the coronation falls apart but
that would that would still require some
work but it's on g3 move that makes his
task easier right yeah and the other
this is the final position in the game
because after King takes d3
can play just no not have to offer sir
if there would be mistake with lacy one
first takes he won't ever do any cooking
chiku and this is a full/queen and we do
have resignation on the board by Fabiana
as the world champion takes a 2-0 match
lead we came onto the show obviously
mentioning the World Championship match
of 2018 played in London 12 consecutive
draws before Magnus won decisively in a
tiebreaker rapid chess tiebreaker and of
course we mentioned the clutch chess
event that recently concluded with an
epic dramatic final knockout match
victory for Magnus but as he said in
that match it could go it could have
gone either way and they were trading
blows right to the end trading blows is
not what happened however today as fabbi
again has lost the first two games back
over to Vladislaus game what happened
there Peter well the young game proper
is progressing a pace and I've been
trying to calculate if maybe a six is
somehow winning here and then trying to
play against the fact that the king will
not be able to leave that like if we
play a six king ash for a seven here if
the black king is completely restricted
to those like h4 and g4 squares at least
to begin with but I couldn't find any
way to exploit it and our team if
instead goes rook a six which I don't
know how to how I feel about because why
can't we just take on h4 why isn't this
a Drona
we I guess he wants to take on g6 rook
takes a five and King III here's
something that throne of the back King
to worry about not not not
amazing--negative size but I think he's
hoping that he maybe can round up and
pick up a 495 while the black King is so
completely cut off from all the a4 is a
yeah we play f3 for the time being and
when we mark time with blacks yeah I
don't I don't quite see it yet and young
goes for something more concrete our
case what is what
what what why oh why but I mean yantras
gave up the for only five without even
fighting for it which is a tiny bit
confusing to me but ah clever
and now the what's it called the Arabia
drew clearly whatever right [ __ ] check
yeah how do you I know this is rather
there desperado yeah yes they call it we
call it the Arabia drogon in Russian oh
really
okay interesting we yeah so the idea is
blacks King is in a stalemate the
problem is that his rook can move if
black did not possess a rook he would be
stalemated so black now makes an entire
series of moves all with check to try to
convince his opponent to take his rook a
very very well-known stare mating idea
but it's always nice when you get to
execute it properly on the board Peter
who and it does look like white cannot
really do anything about it as long as
there was a brief moment there where
after King D six room D 14 g7 you could
make a mistake by giving a check from
here allowing rookie six and then you
would have to think about things but of
course Yun doesn't doesn't do that and
he is giving checks from from the side
where and now Rob g7 Czechia come ripped
oh that's a very beautiful visual isn't
it
yes nicely done nicely done by Yong who
preserves his plus-one score somewhat
sadly for their TV offense because we
have to reiterate game one was decided
eventually Yun was winning by Forrest at
some point but he did not find that
forced win and the final position in the
game is just very clearly drawn but
vladislav had a credit disconnection and
could not reconnect in time so so is not
to allow his time to run out and there
you see our scoreboard after two rounds
of play will be taking a commercial
break now and we'll see you on the other
side of the break thank you everyone for
joining us
[Music]
you
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Cara Juana
Alexander Chris Chuck and bent Allah
Hari Krishna go premium at chess 24 to
challenge them and gain full access to
the world's most entertaining chess
platform
now anyone can learn and improve their
chest skills with the world champion
Magnus Carlsen
the Magnus trainer app is packed with
fun minigames in interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the Magnus trainer available in the App
Store and Google Play
[Music]
[Music]
you
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess mastery magnus
carlsen introduces chasuble
the definitive solution for studying
chess move trainer uses the science of
spaced repetition to identify your
strengths and eliminate your weaknesses
there's no need to set up a board to
remember which page you're on or keep
track of all the moves you miss move
trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the endgame with confidence
it's a seamless effective and fun way to
study chess choose from one of the
largest online chess libraries in the
world
with hundreds of titles ranging from
classic books due to our exclusive
chasuble courses including over 100 free
courses get expert insights from
international Master John Bartholomew
Graham loss to Sam Franklin's
international master Christoph's alecky
Grand Master Simon Williams world's
champion Magnus Carlsen and hundreds of
other instructors get started now and
join our growing community of over
100,000 chess enthusiasts at jezebel.com
chasuble take control of your journey
towards chess mastery
[Music]
hi my name is kamil plata and i am the
author of the cars break the rules like
that from box key
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the chess oppose one of
the things that we're trying to do in
these broadcasts is make them a little
bit more educational and that's why each
and every day we're inviting a new
author accessible author to join us we
have Camille Flicka with us welcome
aboard Camille welcome everybody nice
you have been working on or you've
actually completed of course a course on
the Kings Indian attack am i right with
that yes yes it was my first course
published for chasuble and how how's it
been going has it been well-received
yeah I think so I got very positive
feedback also it's the opening I play
like half of my chest career if I can
call it like this and yeah I really like
to play those those things wonderful and
of course you've been watching the
chasuble masters you got a chance to see
the preliminaries and now join us for
the first day of the quarterfinals
what's been your overall impression what
do you like the most I mean I'm very
huge fan of wrap it on the breeze time
control so for me it's like like the
best thing because you know in the
classical chess players rarely though
some mistakes but here we can also see
their human sight of of their place
because they're blundering you know
they're heavy full of nerves and that's
great thing too for me as a viewer such
as fun well it's a situation where we're
so grateful and thankful that you're
joining us but you may be upstage
because at this moment that you've
joined this Camille the world champion
has a 2-0 lead and should he not should
he not lose should he draw or win this
the third game his match for the day
would be effectively over he would be
the winner of today's set and he will be
joining us in that case so get in all of
the act get in the act while you
and so to speak and I want to invite
Peter and on it to join in with any
questions that they may have a view on a
Peter question I was gonna pick up on
the line that you said that you really
like this time control and if I'm
correct you call yourself a blitz addict
and one of your victims online who was
one of our participants Hikaru Nakamura
can you tell us about the game and what
is it that makes blitz so fascinating to
you I'm a lazy person so when police say
I don't have to spend too much time
thinking on move so I can rather rely on
my intuition than some calculating
skills and the game of the car was
pretty pretty funny because it was like
free I am in at night at my place and I
just looked for a game I just come and
suddenly I saw a car is online so why
shouldn't I try it for the first time
challenge him okay he accepted then I
lost three next games without without
any fight and then suddenly in the fort
fort in didn't gain number four I
managed to like winner one of the best
games in 22 moves with white and it was
like the best feeling in the world
because not only I had the first chance
to play against the best player but I
also managed to beat him and also a very
good thing about this game was that I
managed to use the line that was for my
second course it was line from my second
course so it was a great feeling I knew
that not only I am working for four
other people but I also managed to help
myself by mine winning the game that's
very nice Camille you had a learning
moment that you wanted to share with our
audience as well yeah for me the most
fascinating moment from today's today's
games was the game with the first game
between iron and promenade she
introduced for our team F so the game
were
vladislav disconnected but I think that
we can appreciate the position after a
move number 36 from black where a block
just took on g5 of the opponent I think
that in this position we should just
take a look at
the fact that there are four black
species on the queenside which are
really not participating much in the
defense of the King site and that means
that we should rather start looking by
looking for some attacking chances and
we have like five pieces attacking black
as one piece defending so it should be
possible to create some breakthrough and
then move knight Knight H to f5 is just
just a crushing move because it just
rips the black King out of his defenders
and I think it is very thematic yeah I
thought so too and that's exactly the
conversation we were trying to have on
air because the game was a bit too fast
pace for us to touch on this properly
but it's good that you bring this up
sacrifice like this with white honestly
apart from this first check for a while
we'll probably be playing with quiet
moves it is mainly possible here as you
say because of those bystanders on the
Queen side which really aren't
participating in in a defense and then
there was this very very beautiful line
in the game which which can ended up
missing which we can show again in this
position but I think as you said it's
important to recognize when you can
start an attack like this simply because
you have an advantage on the side of the
board where most of the play will be
concentrated yes sometimes it's as
simple as that as counting the pieces
but I'm sorry to interrupt this learning
moment because we've got a lot more
moments to learn as we have in the game
between Magnus and fabbi a move that has
just stopped Magnus cold g7 g5 Peter
take it away yeah that's a that's a very
interesting development because this
idea in general in the Bishop b5
Sicilians these days this idea is not
unheard of and I was a little bit
surprised by Magnus choice to play h3 on
most six if you look at what happened
here
Magnus gave a check 5 played 96 which is
already a little bit interesting I think
most people are used to believe that if
you wanted to play sharply for a win in
a muster
game in this position with black you
always played 97 in in in in the days of
your so to speak but right but my 96 is
also a fighting move castles Bishop d7
or key 196 and there's a lot of theory
in this position starting from the move
C 3 for instance and honestly much of
that theory is completely safe for white
which is why I was honestly a little bit
surprised when when Magnus played Age 3
a a 6-bit 1 and g5 is a very thematic
move even sometimes black plays it with
the ponies on h2 but with a bomb h3 it
does feel very very logical for black to
try to play g5 g for as early as
possible and to blow the the kingside
apart this way and of course 95 Ruby g8
plays into into Black's hands because
the bondage they probably will be won
back after something like this for sure
it it does forcefully remind me of a
game that was played in the sink fill
Cup a few years ago between Magnus
Carlsen investment Topalov it was a
different line but it was an early g5 by
Veselin Topalov
they're definitely through Magnus off
his game and in fact Veselin Topalov one
with the black pieces in that double
edge game that I'm referencing and I
can't remember exactly how it got to the
position but things are continuing to
blow up Peter yeah but I think Magnus
here is reacting sort of in the time
time-honored fashion you are always told
as a child I mean always maybe it's a
bit of an overstatement but you are told
that the way to to play against a flank
attack is to start playing actively in
the center and Magnus does that by not
picking up the pawn on g5 going D for a
meeting g4 with a very nice tactical
detail of d4 d5 saying to Fabi if you
want took for me to continue thinking
about Hg you first have to play some
kind of an ugly move like 98 or Knight a
7 here and if you
if you play a G of three which is what
5e did I do have data xe6 threatening 67
with the check which means FG 2 is
impossible because it just loses a piece
and and now Magnus managed to trade some
pieces of the board open up some
something in the center the bishop on c1
is now playing and also quite
importantly his his King side is
completely intact which i think is if we
consider the context of the match King
safety is is of paramount importance
here because everything else is quite
easy a lot easier to control okay
Camille let me get you in the
conversation as well a moment ago you
had just given this very nice impression
of a justified sacrifice that all the
black's pieces Vladislaus pieces were
off on the Queen side and so it wasn't a
surprise that blacks King got
overwhelmed on the Kings side in this
particular moment do you feel that Fabi
early g5 has been justified and if so
why and it was definitely justified from
the psychological point of view
Fabrice anima is in a must-win situation
so playing for a position like this is
something that he kind of has to has to
go for because he has to beat Magnus in
this game with the black pieces to have
the chance for the Armageddon in the
next game so but from the positional a
point of view I can maybe share this
that I was working for more than two
months now on the anti Sicilian course
and I saw so many of those g5 ideas that
it definitely doesn't surprise me at
this point and the move knight c6 i
understand why peter criticizes it but
ok fabric has to go for something 97 is
definitely the most combative move but
I'm pretty sure that Magnus also would
have something I prepared there and why
does 45 works here because this MOU
fights free is okay it restricts the
black pieces but the prop
is that now the pond on edge free is
also a target which we are going to use
by playing a quick G foreign through g8
and the fact that Wyatt has all of his
pieces still in the center helps with
this proponent bracket e4 if for example
if the white bishop would be like on a4
and there would be no night or no free I
think that white would be probably
defenseless in this position but here
having the two pieces on the King side
helps with the defense all right very
very nice and in the current position
for me it's a little bit of a surprise
that fabbi is going into a kind of a
tank to my eyes White's moves weren't
that unexpected and now that the G file
at least is half opened I would think a
move like rook g8 is automatic for two
reasons first of all the half-open G
file but also maybe Bishop g5 itself is
a little bit uncomfortable thinking so
long about a move like rook g8 which i
think is automatic and if rook g8 isn't
your move what would be your move with
that is if the question to me yes please
I have no idea I would play route g8 in
in a second probably as I spoken like a
true blitz master oh yeah very good
I would like spend like five seconds on
playing d5 but then it takes d5 and
Queen takes f6 is coming so white is
close there I guess and so I would just
stop counting no matter what you take on
the fight with and you don't want to
take with the night probably and also if
not it takes d5 there is a five so well
well just on that moment to because you
kind of think to yourself if you play d5
and you go 85 Queen takes d5 Queen takes
f6 you you slap yourself in the forehead
and say why isn't my work on g8 exactly
but he hasn't even done it he has not
played rook g8 he played Knight d7 Peter
jump right back in explain what's going
on we're confused
I think he is he's come to the
realization that 97 Andy sheiks are the
2 moves he needs more at least in the
early stages here then
here's I have a feeling I mean he's not
castling kingside here we know that much
so I expect the rook to appear on g8 at
some point but I think it's a question
of which of the moves you will probably
end up making anyway needs to be made
first and he somehow I think starting
with the sixes you don't even want to
calculate Bishop g5 even though I don't
quite see what's wrong with Bishop e7
and of g8 next move even here but yeah
um I'm a little bit surprised I'm I'm
not necessarily shocked but Ruchi eight
is extremely extremely natural here I I
don't quite know what Fabi disliked
about it I quite like I don't disagree
with the with the set up of 97 and these
chicks but yeah for instance you know
one change is precisely what Magnus has
done white can play Queen g3 and now you
might actually struggle to get your og 8
in exact which would be which would be
unfortunate yeah and in the meanwhile
the move Queen g3 if the move Knight d7
was designed to play 95 and maybe pick
up a tempo against the Queen the move
Queen g3 is a really wonderful reaction
you can you stop rough g8 you get out of
the potential tempo and by the way
excuse me man I introduced Bishop f4 and
this there's a certain weakness on d6
I'd like to discuss so I think fab he's
getting himself into a bit of a Tang
yeah he played Queenie fifty by Queen e7
but now after which before I guess he
wants to Castle queenside but after okay
g'wan I'm sorry just a tactic which I'm
sure her ia interrupt here Yvonne is
hanging though right so we can go we can
go in this way and then Bishop g5 I
think we can even start with Bishop g5
it's also working that is true and we
need seven this is actually on the board
so - we'll have that option
yes but the hang on a second
everything's a 92 595 yeah
okay when
are we sure about this no but I was
smart and he won and I got myself all
excited Peter isn't that far f4 f4
probably works we can also we can also
do this
hey come b7 yeah no I mean yeah Queen
takes b7 is not going to is not going to
happen because specifically as the
Esther said
Ruki fight probably wins on the spot
here because I am Agnes mother's already
played 95 Magnus is enjoying himself
here exactly exactly and this rook on e1
you always I mean this is kramnik smooth
right rook e1 you always have these
kinds of breakout moves 95 Michael tall
especially was was happy playing Knight
f5 and 95 it's open Sicilians um this
looks like fabbi has missed time maybe
he's just missed a feeder yeah it feels
like well perhaps I mean I understand
that it will sound uh I don't intend it
to sound disparaging or anything but I
think uh he is very difficult to imagine
him being happy with how the set is
going mm-hmm and I think this may have
influenced his play a little bit here
because normally I don't think I don't
think the position of the Queen takes of
three logically results in the position
of the 95 I think they're something else
should have been on the board by this
point and ya have a feeling we might
have a guest on reasonably soon actually
in this position does black has any
choice I mean what he's taken he's taken
with the bishop and play d5 and after 23
now after Bishop d3 he is more or less I
think I think like white is maybe even
winning strictly speaking because this
Bishop goes to a5 and then black is just
so completely tied up everywhere and
eventually some kind of before happens
and everything gets opened up and your
position collapses Bishop like that on
there 5 Peter you think to yourself why
oh why don't I have a pawn on g6
please give me a pond to put on g6 okay
this is an opening disaster disaster for
fabbi which is very rare considering
what a great opening specialist he is
it's just the the wheels have come off
in this set mm-hmm and we have been sort
of not even not even talking about the
fact that the second game is in progress
but Vladislav Artemyev is he has a very
playable position here with black but
maybe not as good as I originally
thought at some point it looked to me
like black might just be like much
better but III don't know if I think
that anymore your reign Your Enthusiasm
first of all what got you in thews II
astok and why are you tempering it now I
quite like 93 I think white might have
enough time to trade some pieces maybe
establish the second Bishop on e3 and
then his position won't look all that
all that poor I'm interested by the
opening in that game because our team is
played now the Sicilian was to a6 which
is I mean it's been around for a while
it's been known that it's possible to
play like this but it's not supposed to
be great specifically because of the two
moves with the C pawn both c3 and c4
actually are supposed to be quite quite
good here and Young did play C 3 g5 e d5
in 95 d4 Knight f6 and we we sort of
have the the absolutely classical all up
in here with an extra tempo for white or
at least half a tempo because a6 is it's
yeah it's it's not a poor move but it's
not very useful either but yun played
the move c3 c4 here which i think is a
little bit hasty i don't think he needed
to do that something normal like this
would be 300 Bishop e2 was I think a
better option and lap and endings where
you take on c5 yeah that also that also
is very much a topic I don't know yeah
that's that's a very good very good
support actually because with the knight
on c6 in this position there is this
very very sharp line with quincy one and
then 54 but
Northy not not a tempo down of course
and and after community five Bishop III
why does have a very pleasant game as is
well-known I think from from the main
lines but he plays he for and then after
Queenie for chip I think he probably
realized here that his intended move
Bishop III runs into ninety four and
life becomes a little bit less clear
than he would ideally want so he ended
up playing Bishop e2 she takes d4 and
Queen takes d4 and black took two can
play d5 and this is already like an
absolute dream position for black his
pieces are being developed very
naturally the fact that he had to play
ca 786 here actually stops 95 which is
hugely important and this endgame as I
mentioned look look mighty attractive
for black might still be quite good but
might be three is a clever move our team
has played Bishop e6 takes takes b3 I
guess he wants to go Ruby g3 here but
feels like white consolidated just
inform everybody we've caught up with
the players and indeed b2 b3 is the live
position yeah it seems like definitely
nap Oh miss play things a bit in that
sequence between mu six and ten let's
say but somehow he still landed on his
face J he's still playing the white
pieces right so they just he has more
leeway than he normally would I think I
think that that would be a fair way to
describe it
right ah but it still comes down to a
question can black you know continue to
seize his momentary development plus
with a move like we should be for Peter
should be for perhaps rogue d3 I'm more
looking at property three because I
think alright
I think Bishop before you're giving me
time to maybe play 92 with the tempo
it's similar yeah you're getting a tempo
back and and the difference is he's
played rugby 3 and here after 92 you
have to at least count be from g4 okay
and this might be legitimately awkward
for white because rook takes d1 is a
threat which is surprisingly difficult
to meet them
and if you cannot play 92 then your
position might actually still be a
little bit awkward because the night
does not have very attractive squares
and Bishop b2 is sort of not where you
want to develop that piece in general
now black can play Bishop c5 for
instance and just claim that he has a
very harmonious development and the rook
will go to g2 if it's chased and just a
very nice position for black hmm you
know just trying to work out the tactics
that might occur after Knight a4 there
but he is thinking over what to do about
how he's gonna handle this nighty to
Bishop g4 that looked very attractive to
my eyes for black so mm can can we sa
night a4 in this specific position Peter
yeah we can i I was kind of blows to me
- who me - I did it reluctantly but as I
realize now I was very worried about b5
if I'm honest but I think we can play 9
bits to here and not be so sad because
we might be able to finally put the
bishop on e3 which is a little bit of a
dream here for white something like rook
goes away maybe we play something like
CBD 555 Bishop e2 yeah here come on Oh a
bit on black King mm-hmm
it does feel like white is finally his
pieces start making some sense and maybe
maybe all all is not that gloomy in the
meantime in our in our custom Khurana
game Magnus is just a healthy pawn up in
whaling a day for was played as we leave
to take a look what happened how did we
get to this position
Magnus decided not even to waste any
time on on the Bishop d3 a5 maneuvers
and played before straight away takes
Ruby 1 a 5 a 3 Bobby played a 5 ABA for
it does feel to me like white
probably is just winning here somewhere
if he wants to in particular I was
looking after Bishop e5 Bishop g7 I was
looking at the move Queen g5 mm-hmm but
maybe Queen f7 is okay because I was I
was very fascinated by the position
after take stakes where these bishops
kind of take away a whole the squares
role from the black setup but I mean
it's not necessary and Magnus instead
just picked up the a pawn for not very
much and what we have on the board right
now is this position and I think why we
also missed Queen g5 honestly feels to
me and and now you probably started
thinking maybe it's time to conserve
some energy and and move on to the next
one because there's just no way to
defend the pawn on f5 comfortably or
uncomfortably mm-hmm I think it just
falls on a sphere and and and if the f5
porn falls you really have nothing at
all to show for the coupons you've lost
well in a kind of weird way and
obviously from the very GetGo we were
referencing the London 2018 World
Championship match between these two
players and it really does have the
moti's of a special cough to the
position but in this case the players
have reversed colors and it's like
Magnus playing the white side hang on a
second what's happening here what's the
Nightwind b6 taeksoo or something yeah
whoa whoa f f2 is hanging ah he goes
Ruby he goes through b7 King is cooking
a queen of two King h2 and there is an
easy g7 yeah he is just he trusts his
calculations and I guess he is correct
here even though normally you don't want
to give your opponent an opportunity to
give checks like this it feels a bit
awkward but mm-hmm
there is also Roxas ever in the end I
think rook c7 commits yeah I think yeah
okay I think there's this is the only
move not mistakes and we go just just
throw bg1 I guess and but then there's
some kind of e4 Bishop e5 if that
happens you know things could
things could go quite spectacularly
wrong for for white here are we missing
something after Queen b6 am i I mean
maybe he just goes repaid - honestly
maybe he doesn't want to do any of that
maybe he just goes okay - yeah well Fabi
didn't play Queen b6 we are all missings
ah okay Queen b6 no I am very confused
by this why would you not like Queen b6
his instead he traded Queens and played
rook takes e4 and now I can play I
thought Bishop e6 probably is the
cleanest solution right I thought Bishop
e6 is the very reason we can't approach
this yeah I don't quite understand this
and now after d4 we take on the fight we
take one b7 once in a blue moon black
doesn't lose this position but black
never ever wins it
terrible terrible position he's got it
by the way and rook d3 on the board as
fabbi scrambles to stay in the game but
again we're talking about a situation
where to win this set all Magnus needs
to do is avoid losing and now okay one
okay seven for instance seems like it
ends the game on the spot if we want or
well certainly it sure does yeah it's
sorry it's a strange decision but
Fabiano because I I suspect Queen b6
loses somehow but you still have to ask
the question mm-hmm at least there you
can see how things could go could go
wrong for white I mean if what if after
Queen b6 we play Bishop e3 Knight if we
and then rugby can I worked it out yeah
I thought something simple yeah we we
were both confused I also I did not see
that that's a very nice sequence indeed
Bishop e3 first and then take on d7 of
course yeah and yeah that that actually
wins on the spot because blacks all
night is in the way of counter play yes
they have to form the queen is hanging
mate in one is hanging yeah Camille is
Camille
got on yeah spot-on here and yeah in the
endgame among this even played b5 here
using the fact that the back rank issues
allow him to do that and as I mentioned
occasionally black will not lose this
position because he does have a very
nice central pair and the b-pawn isn't
really queening just yet but sadly for
Fabi he has to play it sharply for a win
somehow and that's I think going to
present a problem I just found one way
how to lose with white here I wanted to
go rook a v e4 rook takes e4 but now I
see Roxy one yeah but notably probably
ends up not happening I guess yeah I
guess they will not play this but I like
to rook a v e4 rook e1 I think a lot of
players were trying to get behind that
is a choice Camille I mean rooks behind
gosh I rip d3 no no no I mean this might
be just winning we do have a 5 4 + B 7 B
6 without the bishop trade on the board
guys yeah Magnus just says you know I
have a plan I need I need to push this
bond first yeah yeah further down the
road if Bishop c3 which seemingly solves
the back ranked issues and now the
bishop is hanging I think group c7 is
the intention here quite look-wise
cleverly protecting everything and like
doesn't really have very much in a way
of counter play and if Magnus needed to
win this game there would still be some
conversational topics for us to engage
with but mm-hmm
because of the Maj situation this feels
like a bit of a foregone conclusion
I mean Magnus used an expression the
other day skin in the game doesn't have
that much skin in this particular game
do you have that in Russian as well
beater skin in the game by the way we
did see rooks III rook g7 with your old
age of 7 and now we are playing a rock n
game which is objectively probably even
difficult to draw for black but yeah
white is white is just doing very very
well there are analogs I don't think
skin in the game as a literal expression
exists in
but the concept is not unknown and in
Camille and polish and bucks I don't
fully get what does it mean skin in the
game
can you just means it means you are you
are invested invested in the outcome it
means that you you you care basically
because you have something rather you
have I mean yes sir probably you usually
I know I know but I don't recall
anything like the idea is kind of like
there's a wager going on maybe you're
watching blackjack you're watching black
jacket you're told come on let's go
let's go and you go wait a minute I got
some skin in the game because you've
also made a wager on the player who's
actually playing that particular hand of
blackjack so skin in the game if we have
something like this in Polish then I'm
not recalling it at the moment okay okay
by the way for Magnus fans it's a very
good day at the office
he's definitely on the superior side
maybe he's winning he doesn't need it
two and a half is enough again these are
like sets of matches whether you win
them 3-0 or you win them two and a half
one and a half the outcome is the same
victory is a victory and today it looks
like a victorious day for Magnus II will
not have to play a fourth game
let's therefore turn our attention back
to the other match Peter
absolutely and you know this is this is
the current position and I think we
found a very very interesting reply
there after night they four he played b5
and I'm beginning to wonder if maybe
white was supposed to take on b5 first
but I understand why young didn't want
to do that for instance in this position
Rubik d5 would suddenly become a move
protecting the pawn on d5 but after like
b2 artemius found the move B take c4
which we kind of ignored and this is a
very positive change for for black
because 93 c d3 doesn't really appeal
very much and therefore yan was obliged
to create this opponents
for which I think black will find it
very comfortable to play against and
there's also this very beautiful square
for the bishop one c5
but yeah I so far holding on he's played
Bishop c4 c3 Bishop b3 creating the idea
of perhaps Bishop b2 Bishop takes f6 in
some positions and what is life after
some thought went back to d3 and then
went back all the way to the 7 I'll just
interrupt you Peter for a moment just to
inform everybody that we do have in fact
that draw in the game of Magnus versus
Pappy
so we will expect that in the very near
future Magnus will join us which means
that to our social media get your
questions for Magnus ready and use Ana
as your conduit Anna what's going on on
social media thank you for the reminder
yes sir indeed use the hashtag studied
chess if you'd like to send a question
to Magnus we will choose one or two from
the audience to ask those questions from
you guys to the world champion who has
had a great day in the office today our
question of the day apart from the
question if Magnus has been the
following if we could bring it up again
what makes chess such a rich pastime and
sport I really enjoy reading through
your answers this one is from SMS HK
saying it is incredible to think that
probably over a billion chess games have
been played but still almost every one
of them is completely unique there are
endless possibilities hashtag study
chess the next response is from none
other than the winner of Group B and the
chance of a masters and in g hiri
responding to the same question that
chess personality is like GM Hikaru and
vada Chester get both of his friends on
Twitter friends or enemies we will see
we will see in the next stage of the
tournament and on that note I want to
remind everybody that even though
anisha's not playing today in the chest
of a masters he will be taking
challenges on chest 24 in his band
and he included this on his Instagram
story I'm gonna try to read it out
propose challenge accepted and replied
to your a quarter with a six I think he
wants to plug his friend defense course
again that he will soon be publishing on
chasuble but today indeed the bench of
this show at 8 p.m. Central European
Time is by the one and only Enosh giri
make sure to tune in premium members
will have a chance to play against the
group B winner and on that note I also
want to thank all of you who are making
fan art for the event this one but I
will merge with the eight remaining
participants and we have another one
about the broadcast thank you so much to
Chevy for this lovely judo back to the
action since things that are heating up
and the real champion will be joining us
to use the hashtag study chests to send
questions to magnets Thank You honor for
that we are not joined by the one and
only Aneesh Gary but we are in fact
being joined by the one and only Magnus
Carlsen Magnus thank you for joining us
congratulations nice day today yeah I
would get I would say it's pretty good
so just yeah I just got a just got to
keep it up because last tournament this
happened as well and then kind of messed
it up later
so well things went your way year from
the get-go Game one in fact and Peter
will bring that up on the board a smooth
Carlsbad if you will Magnus take us
through where you felt the ABI went
wrong to be fair I think he messed up
pretty pretty early because already when
when I managed to go go a5 b5 and
basically he cannot prevent a
six-bedroom and with so many minor
pieces on the board including including
him not being able to to exchange one
bishop or even
one night I think it's extremely
unpleasant for him and in the game
obviously it could have could have
defended better but I mean it the
position is just a dream to play for him
for white and in Game two it was like
you've got a nice little
somethin'-somethin
and you converted a bishops of opposite
color where you know I think a lot of
people would have said Oh Bobby the
number two player in the world could
draw that ending
what was his fatal mistake in that game
well as you know it's kind of a tricky
situation when you're when you're down
in the match with whites in the second
game and you get such a depressing
position it's it's not easy but I'll
just say I was extremely lucky in that
game because I i'm when i played night
b5 on around both 12 or whatever yeah
yeah that was the mouse that by mistake
and i took it so that was just insane
and like you're pretty lucky to make a
mouse that that just actually flew in
much at all so i mean my first instinct
was that I just made him made a mouse
lip now my position kind of sucks but I
think pretty quickly I got decent
counter play and obviously then some
point you should figure out how to make
a draw but then it becomes more and more
difficult time with the time edge and
everything it's not surprising that it
collapses at some point but yeah to win
to win after making my slip that's not
something that happens every day
that's I wanted to get honor in so that
she could ask you some social media
questions today Magnus we've got a large
audience so again thank you big shout
out to audience thank you all for
joining us and honor
you have some good questions for Magnus
we're gonna let the audience enter the
questions since we have just announced
that we will be joined by Magnus so I'm
gonna give the ball back for a few more
minutes but then I'm sorry Magnus I will
need to ask you a few questions for now
my question though is about your
Instagram post today training for
today's game with your second peter
haina or I mean sorry
someone from the Houston Rockets can you
explain I think it explains itself to be
fair apparently apparently somebody
counted the steps and what you've done
there is illegal I myself then again
Hardin travels in every single
possession so it was a nice open jumper
I I thought you hit it well I I mean I
haven't I haven't played basketball and
so so long that my already my already
limited gang was even worse just to to
so to find a clipper I actually made and
made a shot even though I did something
illegal before under still to be
considered a victory I would say nice
nice I left Peter I jump in because we
got all excited Peter and I did in Game
three we thought you were gonna plan a
Bishop on f5 and kind of just sit on the
position but you went into a different
direction explain your thinking if you
don't mind
educate us a little bit on why you
didn't go Bishop d3 and Bishop a5 Magnus
I really wanted to open up the game
immediately but I it was a bit too it
was a bit too casual and to be fair but
basically I think 90 queen e7 obviously
missed
d 5 and yeah I guess Bishop III to f5
while it's just winning positionally but
I I didn't I felt like playing something
a bit more forcing with before and you
definitely were doing great
if you could settle something for us
because that disappeared a bit too
quickly for us after 95 BD v g5 56 ETA X
95 were you intending to take on c6 a
player for oh I was actually gonna go
that way you're asking the question sort
of indicates that I miss no no okay but
both look extremely attractive so yeah I
think they're both pretty good I mean do
you see it take b7 right and take yeah
yeah they have to play Ruby 8 and hope
that this somehow doesn't collapse but I
don't know yeah yeah but then Bishop g7
this might become unclear actually the
other one is probably much better I mean
I thought about it very briefly but I
think once you see f4 and then you sort
of scrap this line and you know that
they move on right especially when
you're on the near the brown yeah I
think so
no I again it all looks very well we
have one game still going I just take a
gander if you will the position
Magnussen in this one-hour TV at some
point played rook h88 and white played
Bishop a4 which is a kind of a defining
event in this game honestly what was the
score plus 1/4 yard so if young man is
this tall so we'll only go three games
today that's a bit unfortunate
we had a disconnect Magnus not a good
day for large no not at all and yeah I
suspect black is maybe slightly better
even here maybe not by much but if
anyone is better it has to be black
right and yet then them to then play
rook e8 and just give up a full exchange
for pretty much nothing at all is well
for you to claim that the side you does
not have the bishops is better if not
mean the position is pretty good yeah I
mean this Bishop on c5 is just so
gorgeous yeah I don't know I don't know
how to exploit it but it's just such a
beautiful piece yeah I mean is any any
way kind of a strange move I guess do
you want to put that I put it on the a6
but yeah some were like he's 66 or
something I mean it what was the opening
in this guy like
a6 every age 63 and then they did
something sometime usual well yeah that
looks very unusual indeed so yeah it
feels like young should be able to
convert this reasonably comfortably
because there's really not much left in
a way of compensation anymore at some
point it looked like black could be
pushing up with some kind of a defense
but eventually the rooks just become too
powerful yeah I don't think there's too
much does there
this looks like a pretty simple
yeah it's just gonna go at some point I
think or maybe that's oh why is that
even necessary probably it's not
necessary I don't know he'll figure it
out
yeah I don't know if it's the cleanest
but I could you know you could also
entertain the idea of just at some point
we're waiting for black to play King be
seven then go rook before would be six
just trade trade the pair of em yeah and
and then the one rogue just deals with
the entire position very easily normally
once the pair of threes traded I think
you I think rupee four rupees six might
even be a threat because we're okay five
yeah exactly I didn't want to count the
opponent game but it might be higher I
understand but it might be winning quite
easily yeah so like but yeah he will he
will win somehow I think that's that's a
pretty clear conclusion here we just
have rook e8 on the board arrow key I
Tommy's there that's and then I don't
know Shivaji a tree which is seven and
then something something bad yeah yeah
well that will be an easy day for us
Magnus the first the preliminaries my
goodness would they had ourselves our
audience on the edge of our seats you
know very dramatic start to the
tournament how you you haven't had a
rest day a chance to reflect on the
first four days what have been your
thoughts I mean I haven't thought too
much about it obviously I mean I was not
super thrilled about my my pairing that
resulted that resulted in me being in
the by far the toughest bracket and also
getting a pretty tough opponent now um
but I mean obviously both the groups
were very exciting to work towards the
very
very end but yeah certainly there are
two very different different brackets so
I've already made that mistake I want to
finally learn what I'm covering here who
are you you two guys say my final
opponent potentially sorry it's not come
around or ding yeah that that is a good
racket and it doesn't get any easier for
you Magnus as Ana has a question from
the social media for you Anna
yes questions for Magnus I've chosen the
one by palish bad wake saying what is
the key to your consistency Magnus
overall these tournaments I don't know I
feel like I haven't been consistent
adult to be honest I mean I lost I lost
it feels like about million games and no
I would say that my top level has been
has been great but the the floor has
been or yeah the floor has been pretty
low as well so I would say that I rather
need to find it it seems that I'm
generally playing playing playing quite
well but not consistently you know so I
think the question of the well well
meant is this yeah it doesn't make a lot
of sense I think your consistency to us
mere human being seems brilliancy but on
that note to your Twitter Paul nage
tweeted earlier he's gonna be streaming
banter based on chest 24 tonight and he
called the Carlson Khurana match his
free show for today our question to you
is if you plan to watch his show or even
log in and challenge him I
could what I'm going to say though is
that the the pre-show was kind of a dud
so it's gonna be batters he actually
he's dead
the warm-up show was even more exciting
than perhaps what the main actor will be
so we'll see before both matches were
decided so early definitely back to you
yes sir well it sure looks like to me
that Yan was putting the finishing
touches the game of impact as one so our
two winners of the day are now known
that it will be no game for as both
matches and in a two and a half half
victories for Yan and and for Magnus
well easy day at the office for us Peter
yeah it so it makes for a nice change
after the the five and a half hours days
of the prelims I'm pretty sure that's
not gonna be a normal day at the office
for for the knockout phase but today
today both much is we're conclusively
ended by Game three you do have to feel
very sorry for for blood though because
I think the disconnect probably
influenced him quite a bit no question
about it well let's get the impression
from and neppo himself
neppo welcome to our show glad you're
glad you could join us
thank you I'll explain at your day to
our audience what happened well first of
all I should say that I wasn't playing
or something more or less not so
that doesn't reveal what's a their
attention on the major and well extranet
was very satisfied for the first game I
would be in case if I found Queen each
six after a king g6 I'm sorry after King
gets turned on you can just say I'm
finishing it free so I calculated a lot
of stuff here I get three and before
immediately and I mean okay I never was
privileged to solve somewhere tactical
positions I mean because of course
people the whole concept was very very
good from me and well I could go at it I
think this would be at least G 595 idea
I think it should be winning because all
his pieces like everything all pieces on
a non green side Queen and African both
nights so basically he's King bees
helpless so I need to do just open some
files and okay when then I finally had
some first week tree them in the cave or
they screwed up and I was really
disappointed and I mean I first like
this disconnection stuff I don't think
it's really good so bachelor if there is
some this connection maybe it's better
to continue the game from there
from the moment because these connected
especially here as should be it should
be even more painful even probably than
for being there and who o'kiku
disconnected actually dead wrong
position against Anish this didn't
influence let's say he's qualification
from the group but in case it did it
would be another story ability so I
think this should be I mean okay of
course it's a responsibility of the
player but same I say same time you
cannot control anything you are not any
enjoyment from ivory or you already
player the only user so let's see and
well this should of course discovered in
ancient Rome or okay one man because
okay what I mean of course if it would
be like a free if I was fine if I would
have found this F free ID of course I
would be I'm very happy with this game
so game to other if what didn't
particularly well opening and I could
already play for a week but I I have
some mixed feelings after the first game
so I thought okay
we're about to draw but I can assure you
should play Queen be free I believe up
to 93 if you want to fight for an
advantage something real and then only
advice on theory with ecigs and so on
very well off a theory but after BC free
I think it's very healthy position for
my camera and I believe I'm doing
ablution did you find this it of Queen
c7 Queen e5 and I would be just much
better and you maybe not much better but
he needs like to be precise already
because if you play screen duty okay
what is this I can take on a free atom
of his pawns play six and his position
just I'd close to a very very bad one
because those bishops make no sense here
is a typical hanging pawns positions
some bad points as well and well I only
Queen c7 a frozen is calculated and I
felt like a Kiki head he has no Queenie
Freeman so this is just a throw by force
and well all right after you into seven
Queenie free I think I took the wrong
one because visual effects should be
more a strong I mean this Bishop of page
one do you want or get fate Queenie 7 I
mean okay this is
I believe fine in most cases it will it
would end up like the position in the
game but we the column f7 which is
obviously a troll if you know let's say
there's some and game basis and I mean a
key but first white can press on them
soonerlater i think d4 pawn will be
ready to be seven port or maybe eight to
power and this isn't just not enough for
in the rookin tomorrow so when we're
going through we need game of course so
we want to trade ropes and so I think so
you secure a troll but I felt like maybe
b5 is not so bad and then okay I missed
the trick
after Quincy 527 so I cannot clear okay
seven because of Queenie 1777
okay this was like very topical but I
think it's this is a very very strong
media for Eliza
and then probably the lesser evil was
just to go to this very suspicious
position yeah I think Peter wants to
catch up with my yeah I lost the thread
there a little bit where we got to the
position with Queenie six there Peter
okay yeah yeah basis
yeah so this was very good or
practical decision because you're the
only one yeah and I mean you tell us
something else people just the screen of
600 you selling in my kind of socking
success is my only child but I thought
like maybe it's enough basically sorry
fleece anyways I mean I first it's very
suspicious this broken game but they
look like mine do you just call it red
roll I'm not sure yeah yeah so that was
a kind of a good judgment car because
you got into this position I should by
the way I actually think I can also play
Queen DHS of Quincy but I think sooner
hmm collapse because I kind of just
protect like as better the computer on
25 for instance is very annoying then is
just nonsense yeah yeah so basically on
the move and for my lap girl I think he
can't really prevent me from doing this
because if something else I just play
your key eight I mean I said Oh Frankie
one I just created Ruby six no matter
what she does and this is already not
that better because I took on this six
we were right reason for that right
moment and berries
there is never some amazing ideas and so
on and this is probably if it doesn't do
go for this this is I already gonna say
that this could be closer to the drone
as well but I think what you did was
very very correct very very fine idea
from the beginning to end but the
problem with this from cambium I think
it should be winnable somehow because
the pawn on e6 is weak exactly that was
well I mean I'm not particularly sure
says at some point when I played each 5m
v 5f also take design my over you're
right
because I have a clear clear clear idea
what TJ has a weakness I didn't really I
didn't really see the moment I was
losing by force so this is normally
means
so maybe I'm very better or in other
options I wasn't chosen by force what
happened in Game three that was that was
very confusing okay in Game three
I don't know if he wonders what once
again I have nothing to be proud of
because well I mean 15 years ago I will
just review this line immediately I
think because I was playing guy was
another player myself and of course I
started to say 6id is 65 and
and particularly 96 between d5 is just a
lot gonna take it down which is not too
clever and I think like we should go
over it if you play c4 I think we should
sacrifice onto doing some under some
circumstances but I mean in general the
best best thing I can do right now is
drop a data base in to see how it's
white achieving something here because
clearly not the way to play on and
that's really important maybe I should
have just played 93 2 transposed to
regular Coulson and doesn't doesn't get
into all this stuff lots of sort of
travel so I gave a c4 I felt I felt
bright myself right now and here okay
I didn't think myself very brave anymore
that's what like me should be free the
move but it's just very complex 9422 93
takes
I think CD 494 and again nicely fries
coming enough to Queenie 5 he has
something like a booster table but it's
very it's very difficult to say what is
this because okay sometimes you get a
similar position from the appeal but I'm
not sure that this one is particularly
good because if he doesn't want animate
on th he's just fine so nicely free
Castle that's a screen sign in item 5 is
my only song idea but if she doesn't
want to release okay then that's not so
clear what I'm going to do here this one
perhaps so this is like a very very
clear and I felt like a mimicking in
general it's easier to play for Blake
here because well I'm not going to make
you for sure and they sold because like
I'm very healthy play with 90c might've
cease or be fined immediately just about
some files for the bishops and for ruse
so I felt like okay yeah I better take
this equal position and play level play
like a panther and loose and the never
option was to play we should be too and
then secure passage into all which was
let's say ten times more logical and
there should be free
no I think that d2 is maybe one precise
them certified B - E - this probably
makes him play queen g6 if he wants to
or else Easter on the opening and here
have a choice like okay castles clearly
but due to d3 but yeah I think I should
try G free on my own myself so if you
please D free maybe Bishop f1 is not so
stupid
I just win this all back and having some
Tempe but another little semantics work
here for sure
a niche for it but easy place 25 and
this was like very tricky for me because
I felt like maybe after g-free I'm
getting better because of the g3 I have
like I might be free and he's really
suffering sometimes I think he just go
so Queenie fine and I kind of say same I
promise
yes my night is on which for my
structure which weekend and probably I'm
going to win before called back so
that's why instead of managed for I
think you should think for now go for 95
and play like every amendment this was
like very clear to me if I'm going to
get any compensation
thank you be not because became there
I'm already giving up two polls or
something I mean okay maybe there is
some forced line but I'm probably too
bad at opening stage so I don't know the
correct for you to flee yeah moving kind
of swiftly on before he played rookie
eight let's say somewhere here did you
think you were maybe slightly worst or
you're already I think it's like you
mentioned maybe we play some permanent
game are you good king that's
particularly I think that that's the
case so you have just two bishops and
well the only idea I should care about
is III and so unlike if he plays he free
if he protects our 7-pole and then maybe
like a c4 c4 becomes with but I don't
believe in some kind of activity here so
probably oopsie free you shall be free
and here some another move but could be
free I think absolutely 7k if he can
ever be where he can never be better and
also goodness telethon for founding the
for finding these bc for because epic
like his endgame is very suspicious with
opponent on e4 and I mean of course I
buggers the only idea so that's me so
Ruby fries a fine chance I believe
defeated fine chance or 92 is not that
good but I think like you cannot be one
was a strong respond of show and you
want to lose just very very very sparse
not be one I think I knew one was you
know smarmy because no matter what she
does it just like we should be to you
and be substitute them but maybe she can
say free maybe this is too much I mean
theoretically if I just play Bishop C to
condition did you I I get the same
position and then I play Knight c3
improves to one and I'm fine with
magicians that's I mean IV one would be
too much if I if I felt was like so
you should see 5d3 work so I wanna defer
constants so I mean okay it was I was
like holding myself from playing some
bounces both mm-hmm preparing myself but
I think I'm very free and completely
fine which it's only wife who can hope
for something but really this is much
better to draw the arrow keys because
was very welcome I mean it
I mean okay it was actually the trend I
thought that was the most logical look
like Rudy I don't but I can be sure
before but I could never believe he
falls into such kind of cable manectric
I think this solution is already not so
good for black because I have some room
you want you want some very carefully
and if you can America you can never be
that sexy for cold so even if he's my
doubles his room the other do you want
so yeah this is surely closer to intro
because because this room beats your
idea
you think you want so I'm not really
going to take your pool but it would be
my initial g5 for each of somewhere and
I mean okay clearly used in my situation
I wouldn't press the car to this
position we went because I believe okay
the opening in the first game wasn't
really stressful for me this was the
level of my plate let me just jump in
for a moment and to say that we've got a
lot of fans
nepo online and anna has a question from
one of them for you
Anna yes there are so many questions do
you yes I will pick two of them since we
have limited I'm a Karthik 91 asked on
Twitch Jana where do you get your
inspiring attacking styles from what
inspires you to play this way I'm sorry
[Laughter]
they are night that five priests
sacrifice
yeah this was like either the 30 okay I
mean normally it's mostly about
imagination so if you study some games
great players I mean okay let's let's
think for example Michael tell and you
just learn from the best and you see how
can you use it this is how it kind of
takes oh it's normally works with all
parts of the chess game so we're going
to you you should watch some great games
from another great players and from from
from a great player but another great
players just some great players and
that's probably how you make your
imagination more more reach I would say
yes so that's how it sounds like and
general I mean I think you like
repetition in first games at the general
feeling like I think it was Kasparov who
said that if you want to stress some
making attack or something just check
your opponent's pieces like especially
the Queen the Queen is very far from the
king then it's like the best the best
probably but we're probably the best
moment to like and starts your attack
and in case the Queen is close it's like
it's a very good defensive piece that's
all so probably in season two you
arrange to the moment when you should
push those are some great tips for the
viewers thank you so much for that
answer an attacking test and another
question this time about another eSport
from smw oh yon what is your battle pest
level in DotA 2 and you will need to
explain to me what is a battle passed
since that you are a dota 2 expert and I
have no idea what he is talking about
okay so passing dojo
well shows the level of your integration
with the game so if you play a lot if
you make on a daily quest and so on or
if you just donate which is also you
should also find a thing which is very
welcomed by their metal pest creatures
and if you don't donate you get a higher
level pass and then you get some boards
like and some good interface and extra
extra sense for your chief of a favorite
hero and so on yeah extra music extra
smiles extreme modes so my battle pass
is level 1 because some some very
generous just send me a gift but
I never like I occasionally found out
that okay I have a little bust right now
okay well it's cool but I didn't play
any game of dota for bust to two months
or something because I probably I was
not in mood and okay yeah I know I know
there is a lot of fun in there other
there are other friends my friends are
playing there is still some of them
playing professionally but okay I'm
trying to focus on just more MORE
that's understandable so as a final note
on that because I'm really interested in
this if there's a way to compare dota 2
strengths to chess ratings what would
you say your peak rating was a dota 2 if
you could name it as chess rating I
think like I was kinda shy but if it's
my best but it wasn't actually a dota 2
I think it was a dude those are one part
of my career because men normally the
funny part that I decided like to break
up with all the computer games in 12 and
11 after a we want some LAN tournament
with our team and we should be which was
supposed to be one of the main theories
and we learned something like 1000 2000
drove John two thousand bucks for a team
of five people and this was not
particularly say aggressive so we could
barely say when take our money for my
road and so on
and then okay yeah I felt like alright
that's not cool and the same year they
announced it will give you the first
international tournament in Delta two
which was like the first price of our
million dollars for this tomography
small improvement and perhaps if I knew
every may be able to stay for some more
challenge try me for much time in dota 2
but okay I just play it as an amateur
end okay now I think like I'm somewhere
deep deep deep
okay that's a deal in this super grand
master level days very thank you very
carefully avoiding your opinion yeah
carefully avoiding the word dumpster I
see I just want to jump in and say that
it's been a very very bad full-day nepo
thank you so much for joining and
sharing what happened today - Camille
the same thank you very much Camille
chasuble author for joining us and
sharing and also of course - Magnus is
always a great pleasure to have Magnus
on the show answering questions so a big
shout out to all of you thank you very
very much indeed
tomorrow will be the other pairings of
these quarterfinal matches as day two
will go on tomorrow the same set up and
then will come out back for days 3 4 & 5
the players have to win two of the three
days matches you saw how they could do
it today by winning two and a half one
and a half and before we go I want to
get the last word in for Ana on a thank
you yes recap of a thrilling start to
our quarterfinals we'll be back tomorrow
indeed with the other two pairs but one
of those players will be here tonight on
chest 24 the winner of Group B a nice
theory is going to be taking challenges
on chest 24 as a banter blitz session
premium members can challenge shoot
challenge and each and he's ready to
play one six against four at least
that's what his Instagram story said so
remember tonight at 8 p.m. thank you
young for joining thank you so much
young will also have his banter
recession but not today today it's a
Anisha Stern he said the warm-up show
was the cousin karana
match and now at 8:00 p.m. it's uh nice
taking turns in terms of the premium
members
challenging him as a banter bliss show
will be at 8:00 p.m.
now remember also that the other players
too will be part of the event of its
you've just seen the calendar and this
beautiful visual that we are just
showing on the screen is made out of
Rubik's cubes tonight at 9 p.m. on
YouTube a livestream will attempt a
Guinness record
at Rubik's Cube so do tune and search
for Rubik's Cube on YouTube at 9:00 p.m.
Central European Time if you are curious
about the Guinness world record attempt
in Rubik's Cube as well and thank you so
much to the squad who sent us these
amazing portraits made out of rubik's
cube Peter famous last words
or day we welcome those but of a very
interesting one and there is more action
coming tomorrow stay stay tuned tune in
tomorrow same time same place more
top-level chess thank you Peter for that
yes very creative indeed I'm curious
myself now how you get a Rubik's Cube
portrait thank you everyone for joining
us and as Peter said we hope to see you
tomorrow same time same place same
channel till then good night if you're a
chess player you have plenty of
opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen
Fabiano Cara Juana Alexander Chris Chuck
and bent Allah Hari Krishna go premium
at chess 24 to challenge them and gain
full access to the world's most
entertaining chess platform
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chest skills with the world champion
Magnus Carlsen
the Magnus trainer app is packed with
fun minigames an interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the Magnus trainer available in the App
Store and Google Play it's time to take
control of your journey towards chess
mastery magnus carlsen introduces
chasuble the definitive solution for
studying chess move trainer uses the
science of spaced repetition to identify
your strengths and eliminates your
weaknesses there's no need to set up a
board to remember which page you're on
or keep track of all the moves you miss
move trainer empowers you to go from the
opening to the endgame with confidence
it's a seamless effective and fun way to
study chess choose from one of the
largest online chess libraries in the
world with hundreds of titles ranging
from classic books due to our exclusive
chasuble courses including over 100 free
courses get expert insights from
International Master John Bartholomew
Graham loss to San chez current
international Master crystal Sulekha
Grand Master Simon Williams world's
champion Magnus Carlsen and hundreds of
other instructors get started now and
join our growing community of over
100,000 chess enthusiasts at jezebel.com
chasuble take control of your journey
towards chess mastery
you